a rarity and we are both live waste good
morning what a flashpoint
ybox is what's going on what's going on
today so we got a special guest guys so
thank you guys for tuning in if you've
seen it on Twitter now I'm gonna go
ahead and pass this intro off to Lord
kognito because in the world of intros
on iron Lords podcast he'll make
everybody blush I've been through this I
just want to put mark through it for
entertainment value so without much
further ado Lord Cognito will you please
introduce our guest absolutely biggest
special you know we got a big flashpoint
join the realms of the Isle or podcast
today so it's a little special edition
for our guests so let's start it up
welcome to the realm of flashpoint
episode number 39 it's another glorious
Friday morning and we are back at the
roundtable here on destinies day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a lord who is not
only a fixture in the Destiny community
but as the host of the first and
longest-running destiny podcast on the
Internet this Lord is a true family man
and this passion for destiny is evident
with everything he does including
partnering with fellow bubble bro Lord
k-dubb and everyone favorite Warlock
Lord Macey sure introducing the host and
creator of Guardian radio Paragon radio
and the enthusiasts life podcast fellow
stormtrooper avid mud runner and the
Titan we call on destiny and its darkest
out his debut into the realm of
flashpoint mom made Lord Mark Turcotte
oh wow oh my goodness I think that was
like the longest intro I've ever had
anything that was amazing dude dispatch
man thank you so much yeah you didn't
research I like that do is a weak word
for the guess thank you for having me
here I you know I'm glad to be here I'm
always happy to talk about Guardian
radio or not cardi read about destiny
or anything just involving destiny of
course because we're all destiny fans
right and that's why everybody is is out
here just enjoying the game so much and
and yeah I'm glad to be here I mean lots
of you and I go back Oh
evenin listener of Guardian radio and
remember was it the first well I say the
first Guardian Connor I guess I was kind
of real ones I know it was number two
basically yeah we hung out a lot that
week man and we missed you in the last
two years which yeah so I was like well
this next one seems like the one to make
sure and get to so this yeah we were
definitely got the info about that last
time so we're gonna try and get out
there to this next one because it looks
all sorts of fancy in Orlando heard you
guys talking about that actually just
last week too so but no I was like
literally I met Lord kognito at the
exact same one I met you in persons we
were out there we had the wings yeah so
you're out there having wings that night
like Cosmo came in we're all like
shooting this shooting it up for a
little while and then that next morning
we were all in line we were the both the
crazy people passing out the business
cards that we had our stuff like
wandering around good I might still have
your business card
I'm curious about that too for the
longest time I would open up my wallet
I'm like looking for like you know my
insurance card or whatever yeah there's
a bond sister it worked it worked for
one person know who you are
and I will see you everyday almost yeah
those like I know we hung out like you
guys were awesome there and I probably
stock your booth way too much but yeah I
was like but we were walking around then
bumped into Barry and then we started
talking and stuff and then we were the
craziest people of all who decided to
start a destiny podcast for whatever
reason but inspiration from you guys as
well in January of this year when it was
probably the worst time for destiny ever
yeah but I think this that was actually
a good time because that's when you see
who the true fans are the the people
that you passionate about destiny I mean
that's what killed me over this whole
last year we're seeing so many people
put out the videos and put out the tweet
saying I'm just it's like well do you
need to do that now if you're not happy
with it that's fine but seeing you guys
come out and and you know the iron Lords
podcast you guys been doing that for a
while flashpoint coming out yes this is
the time to do it you are true fans and
that's what I mean Guardian radio has
always been built
we're just fans the game you know we're
not trying to make it a business try to
make money off of it it's we're just
fans of the game and that's why we do it
and I'm glad to see you starting a
podcast in January of this year like
that you know I Bungie for what it's
worth they they see this you know they
see all these other podcasts bringing up
and they they see who the true fans are
and it's awesome glad you guys are doing
it glad to be here let's talk about guys
for sure awesome
well I'm grinning from ear to ear so
yeah but stuff for today we've got to
talk about of course a little preview
Season 5 we've got the twelve to cover
some changes we've got iron banner of
course gotta get some marks marks
thoughts on a couple things just his
first time in here live and then we've
got some news out there in the world of
destiny and Activision and just some
things to talk about just general fields
of things going forward for you guys so
without too much further ado let's talk
about this week at Bungie first of
course we have festival loss has come to
an end
did you get your horror story mark I
definitely did of course did you I think
you finally got in the last day didn't
you Barry yeah I was really pushed it
was like a whole bunch of life stuff
going on and I was like I forgot I mean
you have like 70 souls fragmented Souls
and I'm like look I gotta get this thing
done so I just grabbed a shout out to
the Lord King and a little monkey they
helped me out and we just grinded that
thing out got some pound he's done and
got my ax my horror story minute Zen
moment was happy man okay can I share a
quick story here about the horror story
I don't know if you if you if you follow
my course on Guardian video destiny
k-dubb yeah he like you locked in a
little bit
me know grated you had three weeks right
sorry get their horror story you only
got yourself to blame
lots he waited till the very end you
know what I I'm sure he's gonna share
this this I'm Gregory radio but I'm
gonna jump the gun here for all these
people had me cracking up like the night
before when we record a Guardian radio
which was the night before festival loss
went away he said I only have a few more
runs I need to do so I made it a point
the next day to keep checking the
companion app see how his progress you
know I didn't what I didn't want to text
him ready because I was like you know
I'm just gonna let him
roll with it and see what happens sure
enough he logs in it like 9:00 a.m. or
whatever it is starts doing his runs
looking good I keep popping in like up
you get another run then I see him off
like exploring on the EDC what he's
doing wasting time one dating the
haunted forest you'll get it well he
didn't realize that due to daylight
savings time oh no at 12:00 and not at
1:00 he was literally on his last run at
12 o'clock and while he was running he
said it popped up in the corner when the
reset happened saying that the next step
in the master Ives quests in was
inventory so he's like you know what the
hell is that why did that pop up Oh his
run goes into his inventory all the
fragmented souls are gone oh did not get
his horror story you know he goes out of
Twitter and tweets about it like oh what
the heck bungee you know he I didn't
know that and of course that just opened
it all up for everybody to him I'm like
why would you even tweet that like
you're just opening Rick you like you
can't be mad about that yeah so he
didn't get his Horror Story and I mean
that was to me like this event they need
to do that moving forward every event
give that little carrot a theme in the
stick I mean it's a hundred weapon that
was I mean it was easy to obtain sure it
was a little bit of a grind but hey that
was a hell of a reward at the end yeah
but I didn't get it so that truly is a
horror story your story doesn't have the
horror story great okay and my heart
just literally broke sorry K do that
that hurts you a little bit especially
to go through the grind too because I
mean you do a little while it's like you
go on with randoms and stuff like I did
most of mine with randoms I'm gonna go
on I got to about seven I think I have
to eight once just kind of depends on if
you have the group that had their act
together but you go through it enough
and you're like okay kind of gets a
little repetitive and that was kind of
thing like I like how for one this is
probably the best like festival event
that they've done for sure but I also
like how the fact that we had into
something to do in the infinite forest
this is what I said the kognito like a
long time ago they finally put it to use
and what we all wanted it's an infinite
thing repeated over and over
and it was like a step in the right
direction is it like because there
wasn't there was one thing to grind for
but if you had if it was continued like
if there was a set of armor in there
some weapons and stuff if they could
bring it back or some variation it was
really nice to see something we could
actually get a glimpse of which was
really yeah and I you know I think also
the fact that you had basically three
weeks and you all you had to do is were
on that bounty which was complete fifth
was of 15 daily bounties he's up 40
shards right off the bat and that didn't
even really take that long to do those
boundaries or even if anything even if
you logged in some of those boundaries
were tied to the haunted forest where it
was what get 20 kills with a grenade
launcher or whatever in it like I let me
just go pick up two or three and I'm
gonna run the haunted forest anyways you
were gonna get that I think I did just
the first week I think I got a 40 drop
from that and I mean that immediately
bumps you up and so if anybody was just
logging in for just a few hours a day to
do those you would get it pretty pretty
quick so yeah when he first happened I
think cuz he knows my priority was like
definitely crucible so now I believe
when it dropped on festivals at the same
time iron banner was that concurrently
so I was like okay I'm gonna make a
tactical decision the first week not to
touch it it just like do my crucible
stuff get iron banner out of the way cuz
that was when the switch happened with
powerful gear being allotted to every
saladin bounty right yeah okay level let
me get that done but week two and week
three you know I'll start chipping away
so I was chipping slowly pushed at the
very end at the end so yeah I mean it
was a cool event I like to see I mean
this is the first event of forsaken and
I think they stepped off on the right
foot we've got black armory which is
coming I know there's speculation about
what's coming out there
I know we've kind of talked can I want
to get your field marked to like I know
the annual pass is a big thing and we'll
kind of get more into the sales piece of
it later how much weight do you think is
on black armory for like setting the bar
because the annual pass is a big deal
what do you feel that's gonna basically
think it all the weights on that do you
think they can spread it out do you
think they have to knock it on the park
first I mean I've already I think
knocked it out of the park with forsaken
so I just need to continue that I mean
we can't have a curse of Osiris type
drop now one thing that is what I'm
really interested in is
you know just I guess kind of I don't
want to say the value for what this
first drop is gonna be but when you look
back at curse of Osiris people were kind
of banking on it kind of bringing story
into it in this new space and all that
from what we know of these drops we're
gonna get here throughout this second
year of destiny two or Forsaken is that
it's really just gonna be a new gear to
acquire so I mean we know like heavy
machine guns are coming and you know
your Lord and all that that whole class
of weapons are coming
what can we assume we probably get two
to three strikes probably coming with it
we know we're gonna get a raid layer and
then some new game-mode is in probably
some pvp maps I mean that to me that
seems like that's gonna be a good amount
of content for us to get but I think it
needs to really to to the casual players
now of destiny they need to kind of see
that hey this is gonna be worth my while
because we have so many people now that
got destiny to for free I think a lot of
people probably then played it today
I'll drop the 40 bucks to get forsaken
but what this annual pass and because
it's not the the same type of drop I
think that we've been used to kind of
throughout the whole series of destiny I
think there is a lot kind of riding on
it and not only just because of to
maintain the player base that's here
which by the way I think they've been
able to maintain players pretty good so
far at least the hardcore players
throughout forsaken but looking at
what's around the corner and when I say
that I mean things coming out March
right there are some big things coming
out yeah and they need to make sure that
the seigneur pass is able to retain
players and when I say retain players I
don't even think it needs to be retain
them to make destiny to their hobby
every day anymore they just need to be
able to bring players back when this
content drops for a big period and I
think that if anything would be a
success yeah I think you're on it
because I mean a bonds have talked about
this consistently like you know forsaken
definitely raise the bar the quality is
high this is what the hardcore wanted
tremendous success reviewed well but
like you say I think the next expansions
are still key to maintain that interest
you know keep that level of quality and
especially like you said come spring
February all that stuff you know you
gotta have them come in you know
division all this stuff coming that the
space is gonna be very competitive so I
completely agree with you it is
imperative that they maintain that level
of quality and obviously we know about
the news that
today about turning colada we'll get it
to that lady b-but uh yeah it's some
critical times going on right now you
guys think I don't think it's as
critical as it was last year this time
you know last year everything's riding
on Christmas iris and obviously they
just you know hit a wall but at that
point it was too late right there was no
way for them to fix curse of Osiris
after the trap that was destiny to and
how it casualized the game basically
it's time I think they've learned a lot
from all of that and so we're I think I
think it's definitely gonna be a
positive reception this go-around I just
almost wonder like what is what is going
to be the incentive to somewhat maybe
chase this new here because what type of
destiny gamers are you guys like
personally for me I'm somewhat of a
collection estate person I'd like to
collect the weapons however I often just
get set with like one or two weapons in
each slot and I just use them regardless
you know with destiny too I just use my
nameless midnight all the time and even
this disco I have my set weapons that
I'm always using so it's like if one of
the biggest selling points of this DLC
is all the new weapons and gear to
acquire that gear needs to be impactful
like I want that gear to make me change
weapons in my slots absolutely no I
don't know that's really what I'm
looking at it as like if they can
deliver on that then hell yeah like it's
gonna be a huge success yeah I think one
of the things we've been asking for is
like I think at this point I've seen I
do like the random roles they're nice
you have some variety in there but I
think I've seen most of the options at
this point by playing enough and you
know it's like I've seen my edge
transits I've seen my better Devils I've
seen you know my vouchsafe so it's like
we need more in that pool because the
random roles helped but now we need more
options for those random roles to fall
on so I think as you're saying exactly
it's like a bigger weapons pool more
variety of things and I think you guys
were talking about this we probably have
to we need some more I forget where I've
even heard at probably multiple places
perks yeah like everybody has cuz I have
a go figure with outlaw and rampage and
range on the master work I'm like and
that thing is a laser especially on PC
but as like pretty much everybody says
it's outlaw kill clip and yeah rampage
and it's like if that's not on your
kinetic
you may as well go look for something
else and they need to either
boost the perks so we actually have a
reason to look at other options like
rangefinder or Genesis or things like
that need to have some weight to them
because if we don't have more than three
perks to go after it's like then you're
just picking up more trash and dumping
it again we need to just weigh those
perks a little better it's that's the
balancing I think that needs to come
with this next expansion as well sure
big-time I agree so yeah I was like
there's there's a lot coming it's like
and it's only like a month away cuz they
specifically gave us a date for when
this season's getting ready to end I
know the Lunas howl figurine like that
thing goes away as an option on December
5th so we know early December we got
some stuff coming so let's go ahead and
jump on down into that but before we do
- what studio is gonna come back up
again for Bungie which is always cool I
enjoy watching these just to get into
the minds of the developers always
always really cool
we've got gambit coming they're gonna be
playing on Monday actually this coming
Monday so right around the corner and
then the week after they're gonna be
doing the last wish right along now
that's the one I'm looking forward to
because you guys actually had the
interview with the two gambit guys on
there is Robbie and I can't remember the
other one see it's like you're in the
moment I bring it yes it was Cooley
yeah Cooley Cal yeah so like just
hearing those guys talking about gambit
and the whole progression he went
through developing that thing was
awesome so shout out to anybody
listening by the way golden Guardian
radio look for that episode it was just
a few back you know the gambit
developers really gave you an idea of
all the iterations they went through to
get to where they are it's like it's a
work in progress we know what's gonna
change but believe me it is a different
game than it started so that's really
cool and then the right along I don't
know are these I look forward to these
the most like what do you guys think
have you watched the rate of lungs
before I've not really watched a lot of
them to be honored to do watch stuff but
what about you weren't you uh kind of
three Long's I mean when I think back to
you know you're one year two of destiny
that was like one of the highlights you
know to kind of hear insight into how
they created these raids usually they
would have community members running
along with them as well I don't know
what the plans are you know what they're
doing this time but it's always fun to
watch Bungie themselves do the raids and
then just pick apart the spaces and you
get some insight into why decisions were
made on the different encounters to me
it's it's I just
always love hearing developers talk
about decisions that they made and that
why the game is the way it is why we as
players you know experience it this way
there's always a reason you know there
you'll always hear things that they
threw in the trash basically that were
you don't wanna come to the raids it's
always even more interesting because
these are encounters that are very very
difficult very hard you know they had to
make sure that there is a I don't wanna
say an easy way to do each encounter but
there is a way to accomplish the
encounter but not make it too difficult
that it's so obscure that people just
couldn't figure it out it's kind of like
you guys play on Mario maker on the Wii
you know like that game it's like hey
you want to make this really hard
difficult level that's cool you gotta
beat it too or you can't publish this
rate as hard as they want but guess what
if nobody can complete it even
themselves then you know they gotta
figure it out so I think it's these are
always great to us for sure absolutely I
think you just nailed it because at the
end of the day you know you definitely
want to know the thought process behind
decisions you know and as gamers
sometimes you know we you know we're not
dead so we have this tendency to be like
oh all they know all they should have
done is XY and Z and I don't understand
and you know but it there's a thought
process behind any different levels also
skill levels of players so it's very
interesting with that kind of stuff and
challenge modes and boss encounters and
just physical game space like just see
how that because let's be honest I mean
in my opinion you know destiny raids are
some of the greatest content mm-hmm you
know that that's what the community
lists when you see the excitement for
the world's first you know it's almost
become a thing now you know world's
first comes up with a new range you want
to see how that's done and it's just
cool to see the community kind of
galvanize and get behind it so I will
definitely be not missing this one
couple but I definitely gotta watch this
one because like like you said mark
these things are really cool to get that
that developer insight yeah I'm sure
there'll be a reddit post all about it
so if anything it'll be out there though
someone will break it down for you oh
yeah for sure
so we do have some upcoming improvements
we have season 5 is actually not that
far away they wanted to give a little
insight into a couple things they've got
one of them now I play on PC mark and I
know typically on ps4 Cognito I know
you're on basic
the Xbox so actually I kind of got all
three me I don't see some of this as bad
what are you guys loading times like
whether it's driving around in certain
platforms or going into certain areas
would what are you guys like because
that's a big point right here this
update coming with what they put in the
table I think is the most important
thing I've seen and a half like this
huge although I was laughing I forgot my
podcast I was in sue the other day and
they were talking about some other game
and just saying how by decreasing the
load times it's taking away from their
smartphone time like we had part bones
and loading screens and it's like you
know what that's right like in the
morning when I'm loading into the etz
that's when I check Twitter that's what
I check might need more I can't do that
like now bungees taking you only my
smartphone time but but you know
obviously this is very much appreciated
I mean I know a bounce is playing on PC
it is insanely fast like whenever I fire
up the PC version yeah you load into the
tower you're in you loaded in the EDC
you're in ps4 man has really been
getting bad I mean even to the point
where if you're in orbit and it's like
all right I'm gonna go swap some of my
gear around or look at my character or
look at these perks on this weapon I
mean it doesn't even load in the weapon
you can't even see it like it's just
it's been really really bad and I think
it even got worse since the release of
forsaken list it's huge and I mean the
fact that they have to say hey the
loading times are gonna go from two
minutes to one minute like like did you
guys ever play a blood-borne because
that was a huge thing for blood-borne
steps one time yeah yeah I agree I think
one eonni I'm playing on the Xbox one X
and I have an advantage over anyone with
a base Xbox I'll notice I'll load in a
bit faster say for about start strike
but it's the same thing you know like
Marcus and in a sense of like just going
into the UI I just want to switch a
weapon the loading to go through that
and even sometimes if I solo queue you
know it I've seen myself just sit at a
black screen yeah man before you can
actually get into a strike and I'm just
like wow this is really worse than that
by the worst I've ever seen it so let me
look for console guys it's it's great
they're at least addressing this you
know he bounces his converting me walk
to the
that should be shortly before Saiga
night I just remember I kept saying I'm
like if you're gonna make the jump now
is the time and I but I I got her man a
PC is just gorgeous 60 frames and then
the caveat of all caveat so should we
even talk about he is like no excuse
really free so it is free till the 18th
guys so if you guys are listening go
find a battlenet account and make it
yours if you don't have one already and
find a way to link destiny to that and
just click a download so it just links
it because then it's free you get a big
computer later you're good yeah so find
your way to attach that thing to it I
will say one thing I wanna ask you guys
have you ever guys tried to go to the
tower wait for like two minutes and then
when you finally go in 20 people spawn
at the same time with you like everybody
got their own new instance yes like just
right like on top of you you're saying
just literally like nobody spawns in
then all of a sudden like there's like
25 people that hit the tower at the
exact same moment it's like here's a new
tower that's opened all of you get
shoved in this one at the same time like
that's the thing on PC I see the most is
that tower load all at the same moment
that's the slowest one for me all good
things there I mean look that's one of
those things like sometimes we they
don't even normally have to say this
stuff and this is kind of when we
started in January we were talking about
things like January seemed to be this
big turn of tone for Bungie in how they
would communicate and since then it's
been kind of amazing it's like somebody
finally opened up like the the twelve
and their communication they get to say
a lot more and the seventh stuff we will
probably wouldn't even heard about
before it'd just be this subtle thing
everybody's like it's loading faster now
we know so gonna cool so that's gonna be
coming season five we've also got super
tuning just one of these is I'll talk
about briefly but one of these Lord
cognate oh you're gonna take the second
one so for those you guys with the
spectral blades there have been issues
with this one actually making contact
and things like that and they're not
looking to nerf it they're looking to
actually make it a bit more accurate and
just actually last a bit longer so
they're increasing mail a lunge range of
all the attacks and spectral blades
reducing the cost of the mate the light
melee attacks increase the number of
consecutive hits required to speed up
the attack rate that'd be more of a pde
thing
but this is like these are ones where
they go into like they say the point and
they're smart enough to click with a
commentary before people freak out
they said the decrease the base attack
speed to improve the hit registration on
intended targets they said this is not
an intended as a nerf the goal is to
increase the intention to increase the
intentionality of the attack rate
increase so that it so that more often
it's actually when you're focusing on a
single target so basically they just
want to make each one a little more
deliberate so it actually hits sounds
like you think that that is maybe more
intended towards the PC than it is on
console or is that more like a console
related thing cuz it doesn't seem like
to me like both like one one I think has
to be changed to I don't know just kinda
when I read that I was like is this more
focused towards PC players who is having
the problem oh yes I was thinking - I
was like I didn't even realize this was
that much of an issue
yeah which is maybe on the console
because it may be somewhat all auto
targets and point and then maybe on the
PC it didn't so that's kind of why the
change is there I'm not sure no no that
might be I know I know there's been
issues with like frame rates and things
haven't proper damage and stuff like
that in the frame it's our initial on PC
more than anything else so I definitely
see that as being the thing but I think
when you're saying the aim-assist that
actually might be part of it - because
yeah PC versus controller could be a
thing and then they're just increasing
the viability of stealth mechanics so
small an amount of damage resistance
when you're stealth you it you know it
drains slower when yourself so just give
more viability - so that's actually a
cool thing so not saying spectral blades
needed a ton of help but I know they had
points where to let their effect to be
more you know useful they actually given
it a bit of a buff which is kind of nice
to see now the other one Lord Cognito
I've read this and I thought of no one
else in that moment so take it away yeah
I woke up to your tweet I was like he's
like you're gonna like you know I'm
obviously a warlock big warlock user and
Don that's my main so you know I've
really been falling in love with the the
whole chaos reach a 2 min and that's
super so you know one of the things I
remember in the early streams they would
show it and he was like hey you know
you've got this cool ability to shut it
off instantly and kind of retained some
super energy so I remember I forsaken
launch I'm like
is that working for you I got close
doing something wrong like I'm jumping
to me I'm doing my little Dragon Ball Z
hopping shutting it off and I'm
literally going back to almost you know
2% or you know sometimes nothing so I'm
like alright so I remember I don't know
if it was damaged when those guys Chris
Barrett briefly mentioned it at the very
early State Office forsaken in the arm
and a tweet saying okay we were aware
and you know we're gonna get to it all
right
normally you know bunch is very good
about this stuff I'm cool then like
table after table after 12 and I'm
looking at he parties I'm right there
not talking about my characters reach
man it's like what's going on when are
we going to address this so at that
point I started say okay you know what
this thing must be as a developer very
hard to fix because I've never seen them
not mentioning they seemed like every
other sandbox tuning was getting
addressed to the point where I was like
I'm gonna be petty I'm a tweet Bungie
hey any update you know whatever and
then it's so good to see this so as we
see says I when tuning the energy cost
of deactivating chaos reach early the
intent of just tuning past is to make it
more rewarding to skillfully time your
early deactivation when using the super
so essentially it will be more punishing
to deactivate the chaos reach super
extremely early the less punishing when
deactivating later in is super so the
way I internalized this is when I really
is because I did think maybe one of the
reasons why they were taking so long is
because you know it could borderline be
Opie with geo mags if you like shutting
it off and you're having like 75% of
your super use geo mags get it right
back so I think me balancing standpoint
they probably said okay we have to do
something so in this way they like hey
if you shut it off too quick you know
you're not gonna have a lot of that
super energy as opposed to you kind of
you know using it a little bit longer so
at the end of the day I'm okay with it
you know I mean I'm just happy that it's
being addressed what do you guys think
about the chaos reach I play a Titan so
for me really you know affect me much
and I'll be honest man I didn't even
know this was an issue you know that
tells you how many warlocks I even
players
you know hey to make it maybe more
viable for players to use it as as
initially intended or as initially
pitched to blocks I think that's great I
mean they definitely should and you know
like he says to make it more rewarding
to skillfully time your deactivation so
it's gonna put someone of a little bit
of skill gap to use it effectively I
think that's great whenever they had
anything like that in the game for sure
so lark what is you were I was gonna
save mark what is urs super a choice
right now we're tighten and actually
just this straight of throwing hammers
man like there it's still just my
classic don't even use I mean we always
in destiny wanna always run in the
bubble boroughs I mean it's all I wore
with my helmet same for team but just
some straight up using the throwing
hammers still which I do love them all I
mean that you know the the solar one
where you're swinging and friggin
tornado but because you don't really
have the range on the melee although I
do like throwing that hammer that's for
just your straight-up melee where you
can pick it back up I mean that's great
I usually use that if I'm knocking out
bounties because there's a lot of
bombings or it's like you know kill X
amount of enemies with solar energy
that's the best way to do it you just go
to any any patrol able space and just go
out there and just hit a bunch of thrall
or whoever is just throw your hammer
pick it up throw your hammer pick it up
and you have everything done in minutes
nice I love doing that but yeah what
about what about you advances is this uh
and change anything for you the KS reach
what do you think uh I mean it's just
nice to have like I didn't I remember
seeing it - it was like kognito has so
we've talked about a little bit I I
started as hunter in d1 and then
probably since like Kings fall I've been
a tight and mostly like you as well my
hunters actually met last one to level
up so it's nice to see as an option but
if you like I don't even have the G
Omega by us but chaos reaches that point
where if you do want to just absolutely
Kamehameha something like it's a beast
so the fact that you can use this thing
and actually be able to kind of trickle
it or and I think their whole purpose
behind this was they're like hey I've
got this super but instead of holding on
to it for that one main boss if I want
to melt a major for a little bit I can
do that and not completely waste at all
so they're actually kind of getting back
to their purpose for it which is nice
but for me I've actually been enjoying I
love Kota the missile I don't know why
for me that is so much fun to just be
like alright I'm
just launching my entire body out into
the world and we're gonna see where I
land and I just love doing that side
they're big bosses or I've done it to
the prime evil before to finish it up
there's certain moments where I love
that one but honestly I've been playing
the void lately the void code of the
commander that could made if you get a
group that chains it's like fireworks
going off that's awesome oh that's so
good I was like my good
missile is I'm just terrible with it
stuff yes damn it I missed it so yeah
it's like there's times I think I was
like I'm my gas tank runs out and I like
trickle and fall down I'm like if I just
had a little more distance it would be
good like that's one of those it'd be
nice to have a little more range on that
thing cuz I mean you can throw a hammer
completely across the map you definitely
cannot go cross map with that super be
nice to have a little extra Iron Man
boosters in the tank when you're doing
that one but yeah so a couple good
supers one I've heard everywhere they're
looking to add raid reset functionality
and check points for various activities
I don't know how many times I've seen
its other gigs or a couple of those
other big guys be like hey where's my
raid reset which is a weird thing do you
mean the idea why you think they don't
have a raid reset this time around it's
interesting hmm yeah I don't know
there's a tie-in to somehow with the you
know the resets kind of want but like on
every three or four days it's kind of
that I think if everything is made daily
yeah yeah I'm wonder if it just kind of
threw everything in the chaos kinda with
that I don't know mmm oh yeah they're
working on cuz I mean if you go in and
even it's just annoying it's like you
run through it or maybe you get to a
boss but you're gonna go on a different
run and you got to bring some new people
if you load it up you just can't reset
and front start at fresh so you won't
get you shouldn't get the drop spot I
mean just to start a fresh start it
again right it's weird no so if you guys
haven't played by the way work on
getting your free copy but also free
gambit weekend well these are cool I
like this because I don't know I I
remember even listening to you guys like
I know you got to go to the community
summit and just see in gambit then
wouldn't finally came out you guys were
like oh that's so much fun
there's time so I'll sit there and play
game but for hours and some matches I
absolutely get worked because I do a lot
of solo play but when the matches go
well and you're kind of doing that tat
like tug of war back and forth gambit is
an amazing mode like I don't know
other other games you know something
similar to it because it is it's so
unique I mean it really is nothing like
it I mean the best thing that I can
really you know put it towards is kind
of it basically puts like that MOBA
feeling into destiny almost where you're
playing is it seeing your you're both
battling in your own little PvE space
but then you're able to basically affect
the other team and battle them but not
necessarily always face-to-face you know
I mean sure you send in your invaders
and you're actually just playing
first-person and competitive game at
that point or that one person is but
it's like hey we're gonna just kind of
combine everything that's awesome and
destiny and throw it into this one mode
mmm it's great and then you know what is
this now the third or fourth gambit free
trial weekend I mean it's it's super
smart with them giving the game of
course now free on PC so I'm sure this
has really kind of ended a lot of those
people but even the people that got it
with PlayStation Plus back in September
it's a great thing for people to be able
to kind of jump in check it out
absolutely so have you have you killed
your meatball yet I haven't and you know
like it's like should be even rotation
of bosses like play five or six you'll
see it yeah I should I got it you know
we're talking about people slacking or
Cognito slacking on I'm slacking on the
meatball whoa don't feel bad I just got
my last week you'll say you want to
raise your blood pressure
wait till that thing spawns the first
time use like oh crap like now it's time
to buckle down alright guys nobody died
let's do this kill everybody maybe
that's part of it maybe I'm just like
subconsciously not wanting to raise my
blood pressure and I know like it's the
internal just struggle I'm gonna have on
that thing drops I'm just gonna make me
so mad it's not a sight it's just out of
my mind I don't even have this coming
from the guy who probably has like the
steadiest blood pressure in the world
mud run master over here oh yeah maybe
[Laughter]
like what do you do what's your what's
your twitter pick it just being a
Spartan had been Oh what do you do mud
runs for miles and miles okay so you
you're in terrible shape arch oh yeah
every day run every day that's why yes
the best time to listen to a podcast
people I just listen to music now listen
to a podcast or an audiobook or
something like that you caught up in a
conversation you just lose not even
thinking about you're working out yeah
because you can actually feel they like
carnem unlike my six song you just get
into the conversation you don't even
think about this issue that's a site
record but that's my problem with
listening to music I'm like alright well
this song is like three and a half four
minutes long and I've listened to three
other songs there three and a four
minutes so I've been running for about
16 17 minutes minutes and it just it's
constantly that's constantly in my head
or do a podcast you're just not even
focusing on it it's just like I'm in the
conversation sometimes you don't want to
stop because they're talking about
something you're interested in at that
point you're so involved in it you're
just completely sidetracked so yeah you
like get back home and like walk into
their lap around your neighborhood be
like hold on us here this part like I'll
do that with you guys too but like oh so
what's the news oh we got the you know
it's a call-in show or something like
that which yeah by the way I guess for
full disclosure patreon supporter of
Guardian radio so just in case that
needs to be thrown out there for a night
just because like when you guys started
EBD that's always kind of fun when to
listen to some of the stuff you guys
have done on there I'll just like roll
out of my chair especially if you guys
get to drink in a little bit and some of
the shots you guys heard over the years
you guys have had quite the podcast
night yeah love the show so and you've
been through you've been and this is
like this is why we say it like the host
of the longest-running Guardian podcast
like well I played the Alpha and you
were literally doing a podcast before I
played the Alpha of do once we get a
show for about over a year night it was
over a year and a half before the game
even came out yeah I mean I don't want
to go to too deep into the the history
regarding radio but literally I had been
podcasting for years prior to Guardian
radio so that's why we were in the spot
where the crew that I had in the
beginning we could just podcast about
anything we always joked about yeah we
could do a podcast about a Styrofoam cup
guys about a Styrofoam cup talking about
anything and so I always wanted to do a
game specific show and we just heard
rumblings that the Bungie was coming out
with their next title we were all big
Halo fans and we were hearing that it
was gonna be somewhat of this online RPG
style game they announced it on like a
Sunday or something
I think the review embargo had released
one week later we launched the first
episode and that day deeds reached out
to me because DG was even a fairly new
community manager at that point he was
like hey you guys are gonna make my job
easy just kidding you're talking there's
something you know every week you're
talking about destiny so we just
immediately just kept it going and I
mean dude with those first episodes were
like two hour-long episodes talking
about three or four concept art pieces
mm-hmm it could be and that that was
some of the best times of Guardian radio
because at that point the game wasn't
out yet so like it was just in our heads
this game could be anything right so it
was always fun just speculating about
what it could be and then when the game
came out the show obviously changed at
that point cuz then it was like alright
well we're no longer really speculating
we're diving into what it is and so it's
just show definitely kind of shift the
gears a little bit at that point but you
know we've just been rolling with it man
since the beginning and for me it's oh
it's just great to see so like how many
shows have sprung up about I don't think
there's any other video game out there
that has more podcast dedicated like
world of warcraft you go out there and
looking and you know you have your big
ones like the instance and there's a few
others that are the big podcast but even
all our ones there's there's just not
that much fever for it we're like what
do they do the some of those guys
recently they did that destiny podcast
tournament this was actually I think
before destiny 2 came out it was like a
whole just podcast tournament it was
like third new podcast or something
please say Aye and I'll try to talk now
I know a lot of people you know
desiccators officiator hey I share hate
and you know I get I get it sometimes
with people not destiny players but I
will truly say there's no community like
the destiny it's a very unique loyal
Bunch and at the same time extremely
passionate and like you said from your
perspective you know mark as far as like
you being there from the very beginning
right seeing this thing of all before we
kind of knew what it was gonna become
and it has to be interesting from your
perspective just to see that right just
to see that growth in and this passion
still continue on you know all
throughout what's going on now and I'll
say we're gonna get into a the the whole
Activision earnings car
but oh yeah I'm very curious like this
like how does it feel you you would kind
of like the Mount Rushmore disc I mean I
step back sometimes like like this
Guardian come this is this path Arden
Khan was probably one of the most
impactful ones yet and and every year
just gets bigger and bigger but for a
couple reasons one was my wife got to go
with me this time and so we've had a lot
of you know I always come back from
Guardian con and I tell her like oh we
have all these people that are there and
you know they come up to me and they say
oh I love this show and you know think
you're not I'm I'm just a humble person
or I at least hope I am too many people
so you come up I'm gonna walk to you you
know have a just a great conversation
but for her to see that or people that
come up and and it really this time
showed the amount of people that have
just discovered podcasting not
necessarily Guardian radio like people
that would come up and say hey man you
know it's nice to meet you I gardening
radio was my first podcast and now I
listen to all these other ones oh and I
started a show about yeah that's
literally me by the way like I'm little
you're literally my first and since then
like IGN and others and things like that
you're literally the first podcast I
ever listened to that's awesome man like
to me that is just the best because for
me I love talk radio like talk radio
something I've always been into you know
I was a very early like serious radio
subscriber as soon as they launched that
I just I mean listening to podcasts when
you had to basically burn them I had I
had like rewritable CDs because I didn't
have a pod iPod at that point and so
like that's what I did and I mean even
the fact we're talking about podcasts
we're doing this on youtube and twitch
right now and this is considered a
podcast the term podcast is more for an
iPod right but like it now has become
way more than that it's not just on an
iPod it's it's just a talk radio show
essentially and and anybody can do it
and I love it because you can find a
show that on a topic of anything you're
interested in like my wife we came back
from Guardian con and when I was talking
about you know podcast you can find what
you want to listen to she's a huge 9:02
a no fan from when she was kid went out
found a podcast of some silly
Oh she'll do it all the time but she you
know listen to it at her walk it she's
like well it's kind of funny to hear
them I love it and I'm so glad that you
guys are doing the show and people have
found podcasting I don't know it's to
talk about my perspective on Takagi know
it's just wild manda to see what this
community has become I mean Guardian got
itself and the money they raise is nuts
first year of Guardian radio we did an
extra live stream which kudos to the
extra life team I think it was about ten
years of extra life they did this past
weekend we did an extra life stream and
we raised like twelve hundred dollars
and at that and that was like the little
tiny destiny community we had like more
console involved life was involved this
is 2014 the game wasn't even out at this
point and we thought that was the most
amazing thing ever
flash forward to Guardian con 2018 and
we raised almost three million dollars
bananas man like there's no community
like it I'm sorry it's because that
that's the thing I always tell people a
you know the whole st. you thing what
you guys do and then you know just a
community coming together I've never
seen that and there's no disrespect to
any other game but anyone else as a fan
of this
I personally has a game I've been gaming
a long time I've never seen that it's
just it's truly remarkable man and
Guardian come you know full disclosure
like that's where me and Yvonne's his
met and he was just like you know I'm
talking to someone I can see just as
much passion about this damn game I just
kept talking for hours and hours and you
know we broach the subject it's like
let's do it I know it's probably not at
the best time desgas history but we love
this game so much so let's talk about
the things you know that can hopefully
get out to the right people and maybe
improve and just talk about our
experiences so really cool to see you
guys continue to do what you do and just
trailblaze like you guys are the
Trailblazers and we're very appreciative
hmm thanks me yeah I was gonna say like
the one that when they did the Destiny
year one recap video and I literally
heard the Guardian radio blip in there
and I was like oh there they are like
that that little moment is like is like
you guys are cemented forever to two
things have happened in my my quote
unquote podcast career that
I'm done like what do I need to do this
one was definitely that like that they
deed should reach that right before they
did which if you guys haven't seen it go
watch the destiny your one video that
Bungie put out and the video basically
starts you got like byph more console
and us and you hear our music going if
you watch that video there's all these
little clips it's you hear my voice pop
up a lot and each said when they made
the video they literally went back and
were like hey what was happening
throughout the year of destiny oh let's
just go to Guardian radio because they
were putting out a show every week
Guardian radio and one of the coolest
things that I never thought about as we
were doing it is it is the full history
of Destiny basically in the public eye
you can go back to any episode and know
what was going on in the community and
where it was and each said they
basically used Guardian radio as the
road map like okay
we're gonna do this so like when they
start talking about house of wolves you
hear my voice saying like you know here
we are guys we have the announcement
we're house of wolves it comes out more
paint or whatever it is and like that
was so cool to go back and see that and
even played that at e3 like if you're
waiting in line to play I guess the time
was taking king and read that video was
playing so like that right there was
like that I'm done
like dude and the other thing just as a
podcaster that completely blew me away
and this was even early on this was the
week destiny came out actually was like
two or three weeks after that the
original destiny was we were literally
the number one gaming podcast on iTunes
Wow I mean I didn't even that was it
Apple reached out to us they put us up
on the front page of just podcasts on
iTunes so it was like big Guardian radio
logo and then like Bill Maher's
real-time and like I mean cereal wasn't
out at the time it was a big podcast
like cereal sitting there and I was like
that's it I'm hearing from podcast guy
and bomb I'm above IGN like you know
that's it and so that that's still me I
still have a screenshot of that man that
was one of the coolest living of all
time
uh sure about that but it just that
really was kind of it you know the funny
thing is here I'm talking about my wife
I show my wife and she's like that's
cool like do you not know what this
means or you want entertained no that's
that's amazing no no but it's been an
awesome journey of the whole way through
but watching you guys and just being a
fan like the entire time so right it's
like it's well desert you guys always
have had like I mean you're the host who
just like takes that thing week after
week and you have been and you've been
through like almost a complete change of
people that you've had on that thing
like the original cast nobody is there
lights almost well the two guys first
well it was me Derek yeah and Watts and
then Craig came on like six episodes
later and then none of them are there
anymore man you know Bell came in well
well I guess wife came in and then Bell
came in and then Kate up and then Sean
and now we just got the three the three
hosts yeah so it's that's that's
literally what happens on this will be
like let's talk about this 20 minute
tangents happen and they that's the
whole point so we wanted to get you on
man and that's that's the awesome stuff
to hear so know you're all good that's
that's why I asked you might if we had a
time limit because we usually don't we
call this thing flashpoint usually turns
into one point so heads up guys season
four so pretty much the first season of
forsaken is going to end November 27th
so it's not that far away so a couple
questions for you guys one because I was
actually talking to Cognito about this
last week so the Lunas Hal figurine that
you can actually get the triumph for
stops on December 5th that's like a
Wednesday this will be the 27th when the
season actually ends who do you think
this is gonna be end of season four you
have the week buffer and do you think
black armor is gonna come out like
December 4th I think so yeah yeah do
this before like between seasons that
kind of like ends then we have that week
is it that per per second they did patch
2.0 and for a week buffer
yeah two-point 0.1 was forsaken so feels
like yeah we kind of have a date but
nobody's really said it yeah so if
you're grinding for anything that season
for specific figurines or otherwise they
did say and kind of clarify if you are
going for say Lunas Hal and you have to
get your rank up in crucible to your
glory rank of 2000 or 2100 whatever it
is when that new season starts that rank
resets so if you got to grind it out do
it now don't wait till you know that
last two hours of festival lost and miss
your chance win tea time change this
type situation uh but we have iron
banner coming back what do you get how
are you guys feeling about iron banner
at this point are you excited is it kind
of just there does it do much for you
what do you guys think you know I feel
you I mean for me it's just like really
enjoy and we talked about this before
you know as far as a crucible meta and
um you know look destiny is had it about
it you know we've had the rain of the
forum you know we've had some was you
know prior you know vanilla was like but
you know once on vanilla tea to like
once the first exotic tuning happened
and it became like you know yeah month
of the graviton in the vigilant's so
we've had met is where I feel there's
always been one or two dominant guns but
this is the first one again it's not
perfect I'm not saying is it you know
it's flawless you know we all talk
Scouts need some love you know as a
couple of weapon types that definitely
need some love but for the most part
it's refreshing to kind of get killed by
different weapons this is cool you know
but I've seen some trusts in there I see
you know cause the wolf with all no gold
figure you know so pulses are really
doing strongly no shotguns are back you
know the dust rock and all that good
stuff people slide shot and with bad
Badlands and what's the other one buying
bender all that good stuff bit ambition
oh yeah I actually just got my curated
version of that yeah Wow a serious that
series man so it's like you know just to
see that I'm still holding my own I got
my escalation protocol shotgun number
able to hold my own with my paradox or
whatever but um it's really refreshing
for me especially I think what it is is
more the combination in the meta has
little bit more variety and the fact
that sixes are back and I love banners
control format like I love the locking
down of the three-point because it
really generates come back opportunity
for me and you can be real strategic
because before triple cap Connie don't
flip this on it's like okay so what but
now it but banner and then you know his
salad and talk is talking the Wolves
start howling and he's telling you go
kill them at ASP hike so I'm loving it
you know this will be my final banner I
think for me it's just gonna be
personally getting some specific armor
sets that have two perks that go to my
place now I'll finish out I mean a
character stream of 600 so I really
don't need the powerful gear but um I've
been having I've been having a real good
time a banner we say hmm yeah I mean for
me banners never really been something
that I necessarily go after all the time
I think in destiny when I was probably
even more apt to play banner than I am
now with destiny to is just kind of I
don't know what it is I and maybe it's
even just PvP in general like I'll I'll
dabble in for a game or two just to do
my bounties and then that's kind of it
like I don't really jump too much into
it but that's just a player that I am
it's not that there's anything
necessarily wrong with PvP but then
bringing it back to sixes I think has
made it much better I mean that to me
was always a format that I liked a lot
more and the new banner rules of yeah
locking down those points I think that
only makes it good for the comebacks but
I think it also makes people to PT fo
play the objective that much more right
I mean in the end when you when you do
control you have to play the objective
regardless yeah but it really makes it
that much more intense of hey we all
just can't be rotating to spot to spot
spot to spot you do need to split up a
little bit and so you know that's a tip
for people is if you see you're running
with four or five people you might want
to move in greater gurgles other spots
before you know what I mean it's just it
really I think makes it much more of an
objective game mode and kind of like it
was intended to be but I mean the gear
continues to look awesome but like I
said for me personally I don't I don't
really dabble in iron banner that much
yeah I was like I'm kind of probably
somewhere between you guys I do some PvP
but not as much nearly as Cognito but
for me as usual for my whole youtube
stuff is like it's typically PvE things
so like iron but an iron banner was nice
as they said like they keep cranking out
the I mean you get just a look at these
things they're amazed
the color scheme is definitely make him
unique that's always fun I like the add
of the powerful gear even though as you
said you're at 600 it's like that
definitely takes away from do I even
know I really want to spend time for the
bounties right but it doesn't do that
much but generally I think the control
part is cool I just wish they would you
know take something else and do spin
like everything has only been control I
want to see something else an iron
banner at some point so maybe it'd be a
good way for them to introduce a new
mode or something I can't wait for
because as you said play the objective
and that's where some of the PvP gets
really fun if there's actually purpose
behind it survive
people do not just shoot each other and
play the specific like meta or anything
it's like if I gotta go run an objective
I might play a different you know I
might play co2 the missiles so I can't
really slam that point as opposed to
just go in hammers to hit him from far
away so it'll mix it up a little bit so
it is nice but just would be good to see
a variety in the place doc go ahead can
I confess something with my PvP I still
always rock the Vigilant swing really is
funny you said that I just got the
catalyst not to cut you and it's still
possible what's totally viable bro like
it every time I use a paper like oh
you're using that it's like easy mode
it's like well yeah it works okay still
works like I'm using it and that's when
I was talking earlier about like give me
a reason to put my weapons down
that's one weapon that it just works for
me in PvP and so like sometimes yet
assure it is fun to switch it and I hope
the scout rifle medic does come back
because I always use my mida I mean
that's the thing I would use my might
and you're one they just they're in
destiny one just because that became my
go-to weapon it worked and I love using
it now it's the vigilance it's pulse
rifles right now for me I mean it's just
where it's at well yeah mine's a go
figure and it's a laser beam and I love
it it's got outlaw rampage or full range
master work excellent first one actually
spent the Khorasan and the long-distance
scope so it's almost like six range so
it's a piece that's my I use my go
figure in gambit a lot I was worried
yeah absolutely
so iron banner is gonna be next week so
it'll be good that actually didn't throw
that was the last name iron banner came
up everything was going on at the same
time I'm like ah like too much it was
festival iron banner
shattered thrown weak all that stuff was
going on the same time so now it'll be
like a really down tame week so if I do
want to dabble I won't feel like I'm
missing as much which will be nice
because last time it was too much stuff
but yeah they did say triumph sorry
settings so keep that in mind if you
need to grind something out every rank
resets on the 27th so definitely get
your grind out for those if you guys
need to shout out to some artists but
just any of it by the way the art from
the Destiny community just like keep see
it pop up on Twitter all that's amazing
so many things that come through whether
it's like the charcoal drawings or just
the pencil sketches of weapons or this
right here there's the art is always so
so cool so yeah there's some on Twitter
just go look up like Bungie or destiny
artists and they're just be like people
who just love drawing art they're
amazing so go check some of those out
they're really really cool another one
right here
yes some other and that that a quick
hotfix out there they're for a friend
and stuff is going on so if you need to
know any of the main issues going on
with forsaken they have their list here
basics of you know weekly raid bounties
that weren't completely going through
their rotation just little glitches
stuff like that just check them out they
definitely got some stuff on works I'm
not gonna read them verbatim to you guys
that's for other people not so much us
are you guys real quick are you guys
trying to hook up with someone to do the
refer-a-friend just to get the items
yeah like you because that actual shader
looks amazing because it moves yes I
like that like shimmers school
yeah that one looks cool the ship like I
wish they would have done like a unique
ship for it because it still looks like
a normal one but with this yeah but yeah
just overall those are cool actually
kind of thought about you know just
seeing about doing a giveaway and just
literally part of the giveaways like I'm
gonna run through it with you just to do
that kind of thing for fun just to bring
somebody new to the table so hmm I don't
know it could be one of those fun ones
but yeah they said they're excited for
destiny two seasons of the forge coming
up quick which I'm sure we all know when
that's gonna come season four ends on
the 27th so that's pretty much a wrap on
that so that's the general rundown of
the 12 for you guys so nothing too crazy
but we are not that far away I was
honestly hoping we get the black army
like launch trailer because they know me
too again I was literally like come on
come on like come on let me get marks
gonna be here perfect timing it's
literally on Tuesday I'm sure it's
literally next look I wanted to ask you
to do you guys ever feel it because you
record on
they and like your usually because we
try and we tried to time this because it
worked out for twelve and timing and
everything like that and it just works
because it's the day after the twelve
but you guys going on Monday you're like
you got a few days and usually
everything drops Tuesday Wednesday
you're like I gotta wait a week to talk
about this does that ever get you
sometimes uh well it used to I'm trying
to think we used to do the show either
Tuesdays or Wednesdays and there was a
legitimate reason why we moved to
Mondays I couldn't even tell you what
that reason was and then the time we
recorded the show was always because
byph was on in England and so it's kind
of it was the right time but now we
can't really move to Tuesdays because
Sean is always streaming to reset
basically on Tuesdays we probably could
move to another night we just haven't
really honestly talked about it and in
the end I mean it's just like you know
we've been doing the show for so long
it's kind of a Monday staple I'm sorry
yeah let's do it on Monday and yeah it
does suck I mean we do I'll be honest we
do get emails from people saying like
why do you guys do the show on Mondays
or they listen to it on Tuesdays and at
that point it's like you know it's
already old news like the resets already
happened but we've just been doing it
for so long man that it's just like okay
because I don't know of a lot that lunch
is on Monday so it's actually my first
thing of the week so cool I appreciate
you but we've got big news drop
yesterday talking about destiny too in
their earnings call basically what
they're kind of saying is destiny too is
underperforming and me in my head I'm
kind of going okay and now another
business I know that all their things
they have stockholders all that type of
those are all pieces in factor to do
this but so the idea is if it's
underperforming where is this gonna go
so before we dive too far into any
details things like that just from what
you guys have read your thoughts so far
mark I'll leave it to you first what do
you think on this just like this whole
feeling of what this could do for the
future
well I mean first just kind of looking
at is it underperforming I mean
obviously financially to what their
numbers were what their goals were it I
guess it is right it is underperforming
and one of the things early on this was
probably two or three weeks after
forsaken launch I remember talking about
this on Guardian radio I went in and
looked at the trophies
for forsaken and if you look at the
trophies on playstation and again this
this isn't a number that anybody can
take for four fact across the other two
platforms as well but the way it works
for the trophies on playstation is you
have destiny - and so you have all the
trophies there that takes into account
every single person that has owned their
owns destiny - and then beneath that is
forsaken as the dlc then within that you
have your trophies so when you look at
those forsaken trophies it's not
necessarily people that are on forsaken
it's people that own destiny to have got
this trophy currently right now 10.2
percent of people have made it to the
Dreaming City at that point you could
assume that everybody that owns destiny
- only 10.2 of those people have made it
to the Dreaming City now then you can
also say alright well does that mean
every person that bought for sake you
made it to the Dreaming City I'd say
probably not but probably like 80
percent of those people 70 percent
because most people are just gonna play
the campaign and play the campaign for
say can you make it to the Dreaming city
so only then if we just take that number
at its face value only 10% of people
that bought destiny - or I mean hell we
could even say got it for free now but
this number when we were talking about
it two or three weeks after for sake and
that number was like 5% so the numbers
actually gone up but only 10% of people
bought it so like was that when they're
looking at its underperforming it's like
how many copies of Destiny - on
PlayStation did they sell and only 10%
of those people they were able to retain
for the expansion oh that is kind of a
low number right at that sure the
hardcore community us we love this
expansion I mean this is destiny - is in
the best space it's ever been and I mean
he'll destiny is almost in the best
space that's ever been and with Forsaken
but they're kind of right with that
number man and I would attribute it to
just the reception that the original
destiny 2 got and then all the stories
and all the publicity bad publicity you
saw around it just shied people away mmm
socks man topic like where we gonna be a
big topic we're gonna be you guys
strapped in you're ready here we go
I mean listen at the end of day when the
news broke and I saw this in shadow of
Judge fryer those guys from kotaku
I've read it and I'm like it's
interesting because like you said like
what's it like as a hardcore dashboard
fan you're happy right now like that
sneeze in the best place it's probably
ever been we can we've had this
discussion in the mountains where we
ranked it and we say could this be the
greatest expansion and we we had like a
vote right we're like this surpassed
thinking you know we talked about it as
a whole and um is it perfect no I mean
but it's damn good so you know I've seen
the news breaks and you hear this and
you know to me it's never a good sign
when see oh oh oh you know the publisher
is talking about you know announcing
that hey this is not what we expected
that this is underperforming that's not
a good sign and um you know obviously I
agree completely from the standpoint
that destiny - I believe the launch of
vanilla destiny - had a honeymoon phase
you know they did kind of casual eyes
the game they've alienated the hardcore
at that point you know once the casuals
every member the sales were initially
strong I remember where there was a very
strong I remember the MPD's we a shout
of Matt piscatella from the NPD group
we've had one on our podcast before you
know remember that September it did well
it was a strong honeymoon phase but as
the layers peeled back and then you
realized about the endgame and you
realize about how everything was so easy
to get and the casual guys once they're
done they're done you know they're
coming so what was left was the hardcore
who have now become disgruntled and now
they like you know this game I'm not
playing anymore and you know they
completely this and you know back then
it was fours the sandbox was slow you
know they were giving out endgame
content like it was candy you were bit
so I get it and I think what really did
the damage II is that the trust was
broken because it's like oh no not again
after d1 had a rough vanilla launch and
then injury yeah it can King period so
it's like there's no way you guys could
make the same mistake again that was
kind of like you know the feel so damn
drafts that was probably like the nail
in the coffin
dude it was cursive Osiris but there was
also coupled in with the exp throttling
right wasn't it it was like the same
time it was all right there in December
and everybody
just like oh my god and and this was hot
off the heels of the Star Wars
Battlefront
new create issues and it was just this
perfect storm of everything coming
together and it was like gamers just
hating on somewhat rightfully so
definitely I mean the way they vocalize
it was a little to me I would say it's
not not the proper way to do that but
still yeah and I think that scar is is
evident in forsaken sales absolutely
said you get to that you fast-forward
war mine you know okay story okay solid
in games or the right track Trevor
improving and whatever but ultimately
when I see the statements and he's like
hey you know this is not just not
performing we've not seen the full core
reengaged destiny and he's saying that
he said you know a lot of people in wait
and see and I know for a fact I have
friends you know again this is my
sponsor that were hardcore d1 guys and
they feel scarred they come even when
forsaken came out I'm like doing it good
this is the time a lot I would say about
60 to 70% of them came back was I okay
no I see what you're saying cardio it is
good this is you know random roles are
back six is everything I like is back
cool but there was I would say about a
40 percent base of mine that was
hardcore do you want they were like Nam
and I can't trust it so it's like that
that abuse abused abusive relationship
like I can't come back so you know it is
means that so ultimately you know fast
forward to last what I'm going to say
which is you know where we are now and
obviously know the game is in a good
place the gameplay but when I hear
statements like we're looking at ways we
can monetize it's when I hear those kind
of statements those are red flags to me
I'll be honest and I don't like the vibe
because now you know we just went
through festival loss which was not
festival of the cost and it was well
renowned and the ever versus is in the
best place ever you can literally get
everything by gameplay and earning you
know for the most part right except the
iron banner emo
I gotta buy you you have to buy it
that's right yeah just like no for the
most what this thing is really a good
place and when I hear the publisher say
that and say they're not happy one
not gonna know worried I'm what they can
control of the IP long term - does this
now pressure them into forcing
microtransactions back into the game you
know three they've built so much of a
good will with forsaken with the updates
that wahb's have been great the feedback
the interactivity has been great you
know what happens now does this I just
feel for them because they're in such a
tough spot that they fought so hard to
get to confront you for I want to get
the community back but then you got
happy with it so it's tough man yeah I
need you on this man I am really in a
mess with this whole situation
emotionally no that's was like this is I
was gonna say for a topic to explode we
got one of the guys who's been with the
longest as well so a good group to talk
about this know for me I was sitting
there reading it and I mean saying boat
you guys are and it's like we've seen
destiny go through this way if it's like
year one it's like then we had like the
content drought of forever that we went
through we had taking king do it's a
little patch to me like okay that was
cool reserved iron wasn't quite as big
and we were waiting for d2d to launches
and this is that debate that we're that
we have and that's where as I say like
January was that turning point or
somebody was like hey do what you can
somebody I don't know who where said do
what you can to try and fix this game
talk to your community be more open
patch it faster do whatever you
absolutely have to do and that is when
we saw this like complete like turn the
ship moment when they started doing
monthly patches for destiny to and we
talk about those all the time everything
that was comin the calendars that we've
seen we'd never have had stuff like that
before now on top of like what we get in
forsaken is this I mean we get a whole
entire world for in-game we get a raid
that had one of the longest like ever
completions and just as ongoing like
festival loss the way that came through
the way they've handled
microtransactions like not overbearing
giving you more options so many things
have been going well to see this thing
turn and say hey it's underperforming
it's like it's one of those things
that's like if you were a sales person
job it's like okay oh you hit your goal
well let's just move that goal up cuz
you know you didn't count this is a new
goal in cycle what the hell's the point
in a goal if I can't ever hit the target
if it's moving it's like I know that
like curse of Osiris was that point and
one of my friends is a really really
good example he and I had played this
for so long and it's he's the one that I
would always play with like we had a
group in d1 in vanilla
they fell off I played with him all the
way through curse of Osiris he fell off
after curse of Osiris and even by warm
lined and for him to do that was the
moment where you're like curse over
sires burned like that final bridge that
some people gave a moment for and that's
been that hard piece for them to really
come back like forsaken it's like okay
people have seen it it's there they're
doing the good things about making it
free PlayStation Plus and they have that
xbox sorry apparently maybe you'll get
yours next but all those little pieces
have been these efforts to try and get
people to see it be like hey we this is
the best it's ever been come check it
out like it's still an amazing game and
I'm I'm with you Cognito it's like I'm
worried that Activision is going to push
something this is gonna take away from
all the good things that Bungie has
really tried to do to make this a a good
like the grind is real but I've seen
people hey I finally got everything to
600 and it's like it's real but it feels
about right it doesn't feel too easy it
doesn't feel too hard you can't get
there without doing the raid if you raid
you'll get it quicker like so many
things they've done well it's this
worries me kind of to my soul about this
game because if Activision casual eise's
it all over again just to get people in
I'm gonna go right now right you
mentioned earlier the you know the
community summit they did when was that
March or April and I was one of the
people that got to go to that and the
reason they brought us all in was to try
to figure out how to bring the Hobby
back to destiny and honestly I think
forsaken has done that it makes it where
even if you are 600 you there's always
something to chase be it go on your
collections find a weapon uh to grind
for or searching for that perfect was
perfect perks to find whatever their the
hobby is back in destiny and yes the
grind can be real but at least you have
something that you're working towards
but the problem I think with this
monetization for me when I sit back and
look at it is is you know it's like
alright what are they going to casual
eyes it II
and more maybe but I think right now so
much has been being worked on with
destiny 3 which that's a whole other
topic with the rumor mill and all Jeremy
I'm Matt we're hearing much more RPG
elements that to me says that's not
casual izing it and at this point I
don't think they would ever go back and
change really things to casual eyes
whatever destiny 3 is currently right
now yeah but I look at what happened
over the last week at Blizzcon and I say
oh my god diablo immortal and the
company there is a company that is also
involved in that whole issue and that's
Nettie's well a few months ago Nettie's
put a hundred million dollars into
Bungie yep so that makes me wonder how
much of which which so far while we know
about that is more investment into
whatever maybe bungees next project is
which probably many of you have seen
it's that matter we had that logo that
trademark filing for matter but it
wouldn't surprise me if Activision says
all right well destiny is kind of
underperforming why don't we find a way
on the mobile side of things using that
ease to maybe pulling money which
personally for me sure if that means
that they put something out that they
can make money on that side that then
gets funneled into more budget into my
console or my PC version of destiny - or
destiny sure I'm all for that
because in the end I don't need to play
that game the whales that will spend
thousands on whatever that thing is will
fund my enjoyment of my game that I pay
$60 for sure I'm in on that however I
can definitely see the gaming community
going crazy over something like that and
and not appreciating that because in the
end that will probably come out and you
won't get a drop of destiny to because
they're working on that that product and
it just becomes this whole mess and you
know it's it's almost like gaming
development right now it's almost like
they're damned if they're doing their
Dan'l they don't like there's there's
you have your community you're
constantly battling at because at no
time in the history of video games have
developers ever been able to be in such
direct contact with their community I
mean yesterday I saw a warframe they're
getting ready to drop their new drop of
the Fortuna the four to the head of
development at Digital Extremes
was just running a stream of him at his
desk saying like yeah well we're fixing
this bug right now it'll be a few more
minutes before we drop Fortuna like he's
wouldn't have we ever seen that like
could you imagine when an ET came out
for the Atari and like that thing was a
and trainwreck like there was no way to
talk to those people there was just like
you buy the game and say man this game
is [ __ ] and you either bring it back to
the story never playing again like
that's all we had now we live in this
age where you can just contact these
developers so it's like you know you you
we can tell the developers we're not
happy with this we need you to change
that I'm like you said you know you guys
said like sure bungees they turned it
around with the hardcore community but
now they have big daddy activision
breathing down their necks and I
honestly guys I don't know what the
happy medium here is I don't know like
if anything isn't maybe they spent too
much money and advertising are we at the
point now where destiny can just be the
word of mouth like like you know uh come
you know you're saying you tell your
buddies like go go buy for sake and it's
the best it's ever been is that maybe
just enough I mean companies now relies
so much on content creators almost more
so than they do on the advertising maybe
maybe Activision should start to learn
that and say you know what rather than
pump 80 million dollars into running ads
on Monday Night Football like don't do
that like professor broman and get
phalion Wilson that makes a shot at all
these people will sell your game Ninja
will sell your game more than that all
you gotta do is get a free copy of the
game he's compared for millions of
people
what are you doing spending eighty
million on commercials nowadays because
you got a man racing right now and it's
like I'm sorry no just good things I get
diarrhea of the mouth a lot man I told
you is long for moans like these flavor
here it's interesting because as I'm
listening you talk and I'm sitting in
and I'm like it bothers me and you've
talked about this like I do feel the
strength of the franchises even when
it's at its lowest point is the
advertiser you see a Bungie trailer even
for curse of Osiris the more we didn't
know we didn't know if it was gonna be
good at that right yeah so Osiris we saw
Sierra and just the center manatee
they're actually surfer and I'm like man
you know your mind starts racing at the
grand thought start you know going in
your head about how good this thing
could possibly be so I think advertising
and marketing is their strength the
question is like you said mark like are
they going to continue to pump that
level of money in there when the results
may not be there and then I remember
hearing come forsaken coming from
they have the interviews of day before
my had the exclusive kind of thing I
believe no I have like 100 questions or
whatever yeah like hey you know we're
peeling back on the budget as far as
these big cinematic conics yeah that
nature okay good let's get back to the
horn let's get back to the chase
the loot grind I like it but I guess the
uncle Marcus Paris he had on ask you
guys a question my guess is when when
the CEO all on an earnings call says
this is not performing and we need to do
XY and Z to try to monetize right the
way I look at it is that I said he's not
happy and you know son Bungie you're in
trouble right not in there all the way
you know you're gonna get fired but
we're watching we have to do things to
to improve so it's like when your boss
is in the room over your desk while
you're working it's not comfortable like
now do we think because we know they
have high Moon Studios right we know
what is if I care and you know as I've
had a Richard Hager gaming lawyer on
it's been wrong our pockets before you
understands gaming contract and we've
all agreed that Destiny's contract
Bungie with them it's kind of one of the
weirdest in gaming like this 10-year
thing and then the exclusive thing but
that's another story but the point of
the matter is do you think if there's
discontinued unquote underperformance
that Bungie at some point may say hey or
they may lose the IP or we heard this
major thing here about matter right and
this other game whatever they're
supposed to be making you know do they
get a bunch you get to a point where
they say hey you know I can't we can't
live up to this thing we're in this like
slave contract I don't think it said
they ever say oh we can't live up to the
slave contract I think it's just that's
almost set in stone in their minds it's
like they did the same thing with Halo
it was like we did halo pumped it out
you know get rid of the IP and we just
move on to something else I mean for a
studio to be working on a game
indefinitely or being franchise is crazy
sure Bungie today is not the same Bungie
that was there when they made halo I
mean he'll half the people aren't even
there anymore but still I think yeah
exactly what you're saying I think this
fall we're gonna get a
another expansion I don't think it's
gonna be destiny three I think the year
after that we'll get our destiny three
maybe another year or two of expansions
and then Bungie moves on and and you
have vicarious or hi moon move in and
they're the ones that are going to take
over just like we have three four three
doing halo right now even though
Microsoft that was a startup company but
I think I think they're just gonna put
it over kind of like Activision does we
call a duty videos like I'm you know
what I'm thinking I'm literally thinking
of how respawn Entertainment's sorry
remember when they they had you know
what and then they got disgruntle
whatever the situation was and they left
or what-have-you and it was just it
would break my heart
get ready for your heart to be broken
cuz I guarantee you in five years Bungie
will not be developing destiny at that
point yeah when that contracts up
they're like oh my god I could get a
move on another next thing yeah I mean
that's which I would wonder is it going
to be then I mean a lot of games are
moving this direction in general the
games as a service but is it going to be
something like this like a PvE style
type game where they do this online game
or will they just say in those last 10
or 12 years were just stressful like
we're just gonna make just whatever just
some sort of story driven game or
whatever it is that would be crazy
all right guys take a month vacation
we're gonna put out flappy bird - and
you guys hey I'm trying to like let let
you guys do that's it like I'm not
trying to interrupt you guys get your
was going so no it's good stuff no it's
like I mean Bungie is so heart broken
it's like a hurt market literally
snapped in two
yeah I can't I can't feel my heart I
mean Bungie has put their lives into
this thing but you see the passion that
they have for this game so I mean that
bleeds over into those other Studios
it's like and they've started to make
this something that I think they they
truly have turned the ship and they can
be proud of again if they can try and
keep but our activision had a balance of
trying to find a way of as you said like
I think you're right I think it's like
it's gonna be a big expansion to and
then it's gonna be destiny 3 they've
already said dusty threes in the work if
they go more hardcore RPG that stuff me
I'm hoping for cos coming from World War
craft that is literally preaching to the
choir so those are all things that for
me are good but yeah it's all the
Activision piece but I think as you said
it's like if you have somebody like
Nettie's come in and they do if they
make like a mobile destiny thing that's
the point where people will freak out
and be like what are you making this
mobile it's exactly what happens like
Diablo 4 is in development they can't
officially say it for whatever reason
but it's there so like the same thing if
they if that's the way they monetize it
some ways and for example
so far they've always like talked about
the slippery slope and stuff like that
I've heard that on so many of everybody
when they talked about ever verse and it
never has crossed that line yet and as
long as they don't and if they find some
of the creative ways to do it if they do
this thing where hey here's the I don't
remember what the thing is where you can
buy the emotes for money I forget the
name the new I just did this week like
that type of stuff like if you want to
spend a little more here's these things
like in it's a way where it still
doesn't affect the game I think they can
try and preserve it but yeah for the
long-term I mean there's a point where
those guys if you saw like I mean just
some of those guys it's like I wonder
you see Obama before and after his
presidency it's like the gray hairs are
gonna be coming out if this contract
holds true that they have to put their
like they have you here yeah things like
Rockstar like you hear about a hundred
hours and it's not everybody but you
know there's conflicting stories and
things like that but those guys are so
passionate they want to but they can't
sustain that even if like the Luke
Smith's even if the Christopher
Barrett's if they love it so much they
put it into it at some point just like I
mean you're a family man it's like life
comes crawling back and be like hey
you've got to go live outside of work at
some point and I think you're saying
it's like maybe this is hey it's like
I'm here for the 10 years are you with
us as much as you can be when that time
comes and if they can like if that
contracts like renegotiated that's that
game-changing moment and I think you are
right where Bungie is they're an amazing
company but it's like they might be like
it's time for us to go venture into
something else and hopefully their
passion may have bled over into
vicarious hi moon and things like that
yeah one last point before I was glad
you know I've got one last point let you
finish are you good okay no yeah you
upset you go ahead I'll just say cuz
it's so strange to me when I hear the
financial things because again you know
we just heard like it was like it's the
third best selling game
of of 2018 like it's the third best
right in the month of when spider-man
launched an MPD here September to one
Forsaken it one digital sales
it was the most sale game so if I'm
looking at Activision s yes this is a
failure Wow I you know that number
everybody keeps throwing that number
around I think there's definitely
something a little bit more at play with
that number because does that number
include number one the other two
platforms forsaking Amazon as well as to
me I mean I bought spider-man digitally
but I think spider-man to me kind of
appeals more to the people that maybe
bought a PlayStation because of Star
Wars Battlefront the first one that was
just the guy who cuz I look I'm a
pharmacist I work for a big box store so
I deal with a lot of these people that
kind of come in and like they're just
the random dudes that are like oh hey
there's that PlayStation all the
spider-man game for it and they just buy
that copy you know that was all digital
sales I think us hardcore gamers are
just buying digital games as it is now
but I think Spyder made a lot of those
sales were physical I think just because
people are at the store they see
spider-man these want to buy that
physical copy
we're forsaken there was no I mean sure
there was a quote-unquote physical copy
but come on if you were destined player
nobody was buying that physical copy
right of course they're gonna sell way
more because really it's just an
expansion you know it's not a physical
copy but but I agree I think basically
what you're saying is like how we hear
all how all these just quotes and how
great it's sold in September and then
here we have Activision coming out
saying it underperform it's just this
big conflict of like what are you
talking about destiny is in the best
space it's ever been in you we're
hearing that it led in September and all
these digital sales and all this stuff
and yet you're coming out saying it was
a disappointment it just doesn't add up
let me ask you guys this for you in the
sense that with the whole and then you
in conjunction which which leads to
Activision point is them now they're
offering free weekends we're getting a
lot of fresh completely if you don't
yeah so I mean usually when that happens
that's generally not a good sample go go
to your question I really do here's my
question and part of this is because I
have two kids who are completely
obsessed with fortnight and I live in
is terrible for me being a guy who
hosted a podcast called paragon radio
that was canned by epic because of
friggin fortnight so it's literally salt
in the wound every day on the way to
school is all I do is talk about but how
would you guys feel if destiny and I
don't know what to say necessarily went
free-to-play but what if they do a
monthly fee and they start adding more
content I love like a world of warcraft
they so destiny threes I say they wait
till destiny three so here they're
talking about new ways to monetize it
how would you guys feel about that is if
it just becomes this either a
free-to-play or it is just a buy your
one time shot like you do and Wow with
the new expansions or the releases and
then you pay your 10 to $15 a month and
your promise continual content of not
only weapons to chase new quests
spawning in all of that where would you
guys sit on that realm because that
that's a simple way to monetize it right
it's a way to say hey we have a hardcore
base they're gonna pay 10 bucks a month
it's 120 a year well we'll cut them a
hundred dollars for a year
mm-hmm you got them walked in oh because
I'd go so for me coming from World of
Warcraft that Excellency sounds like
something I would absolutely support
just because I've been through that
model before and I've seen a World of
Warcraft it's capable of now I mean
Activision Blizzard it's one giant
umbrella so I mean they can actually
talk and they've actually got somebody
who's going through this whole thing
because they've been doing it for a
while and oh world Warcraft is still
going after 14 years like the money
they've made from that subscription
model has been good now to be able to
pull that off they have to have the
biggest launch of d3 that they have ever
put out in their entire lives to be able
to hang a subscription model now they
can sell it because if they can keep
this going if next September is awesome
and they keep that hype going d3 has a
chance to do something like that but I
would do in the heartbeat because you
ain't wouldn't basically pay in the same
in would you do $60 expansion $40 and
you'll pass it's just literally broken
up over the months and then you know if
you do more outfits and things like that
just more cosmetics I mean as long as
they never cross that gameplay line like
those are those pieces to where maybe it
helps but yeah I would do the
subscription in a heartbeat because I've
played I don't know two three fourth out
I don't know how many hours I'm at at
this point I know is over two thousand
on d1 I
track since forsaken since this is like
all I do so yeah like that many hours to
me it's like it feels justified because
I like supporting something that I'm I'm
behind now other people like oh for
tonight's free and technically I can
play it without spending a cent now as
you said it's the whales in any
free-to-play game that make a difference
but overall it's just a mentality of
this is going to be that living world
and to me it'd be something I have can
see that that's a great point man and
I'm sorry to cut you off come you too
but like when it comes with a
free-to-play game and this was even me
with Paragon it was like I'm playing a
free-to-play game I don't mind spending
$10 on that skin for this character
because how I'm getting tons of
enjoyment out of this free game sure
I'll throw you ten bucks and I almost
wonder if Bungie I mean honestly man I
think it would be a whole cluster F if
they ever tried to do anything like it
it would just be a mess but
realistically I think if people step
back and actually looked at it and said
hey you know that may be the way to go
give me because right now like what is
it Elder Scrolls online they do it great
I think the way they do it now they do
have some free-to-play stuff in their
store but if you pay I think it's ten or
fifteen dollars a month you get not only
every expansion or anything that come
out which some of them are paid now they
do have their bigger expansions that you
still need to pay for but every month
that $15 as you spend also gives you $15
of in-game currency so basically it's
just padding or giving giving them
Bethesda Game Studios or online studios
whatever it is that guaranteed money
coming in every month so just imagine
like you spend $10 on destiny you're
guaranteed to then have $10 worth of
silver to spend in the game every month
so when that iron Lord emote comes out
you just buy it you're not actually
spending money on it cuz you've already
spent the money to play the game like
you just you get that in the game so
it's almost as if you're just there
saying hey give us $10 a month to buy
something in our cast shop plus play
late you just get all that with it so
for me personally and again that's maybe
because as an adult who works as the
money I have that income but like you
even said about this when you when you
spread it all out it's almost the same
it's just I think it's more just the
fact of handing Bungie every you know
every month at $10 or momwhat has always
been my issue of World of Warcraft or
any MMO is I feel like I have to play
the game right you know I'm spending
that $15 any time I go and play like
let's say if I was spending it on World
of Warcraft I go play destiny it's like
me and that's
two or three days I missed out on paying
or playing the game that I paid to play
right so I think that's kind of the
issue that people have with it as
opposed to the spending the money
because in the end you kind of end up
spending the same regardless let me jump
in oh I love y'all but they will throw
that in the bushes but you know just off
the simple fact that we're so antiquated
that let's be real like we're still
paying $60 for games right no you're
right by the way broken I mean that's
that's a sorry not to cut you off but
that's like that price point is so and
like in 63 waiting for more than that
right so when we've gone down somehow
let me let me put on my lord shell hat
right now he's on the Shelf Activision
at the end of the day like it's not
sustainable I'm gonna say it's
completely unsustainable but at the same
time like the way it's structured
there's going to be some form of
monetization there's going to be some
point where there'd be DLC the model we
can all talk about that and I think you
guys are right yes long-term it ends up
working out the same when you get the
expansion season pass and all that other
stuff but to a casual gamer to go to the
store and say okay boom and then now
you're gonna have to have this
subscription fee and correct me if I'm
wrong chatting this thing some others in
the chat I believe was no yes yes or
didn't try yes I tried it on arm
on PC I believe before a team wouldn't
you wouldn't launched on PC which I was
one of those people you had to pay it
did have a 15 month fee and dude all I
did when you bought the game you got
that first month free and I fell off
after that that very first month cuz I
was like you know what I don't want to
you know destiny was out or coming out
soon after that point was like you know
what I just don't wanna spend that fifth
but but when it jumped to consoles I've
spent more money on the console than I
did on the PC because at that point hey
it's free to play
I like this mount dude I spent $20 on a
horse map
what the hell is that I was like you
know what's free to play screw it I'll
buy this horse it's cool whew I don't
know it's more perception it's all
optics right because you know even or a
casual gamer you tell him hey game is
$60 or whatever okay cool you know I'm
saying then the DLC is coming out
whatever I think it's an easier sell to
a casual didn't say hey you can't play
this or the
this barrier of entry with subscription
see us as the hardcore we'd love this
game we don't care we're gonna be there
they want exactly we are getting that
bad boy right we're gonna play this
thing and we're gonna have enjoyment and
have that steady stream of content and I
get it I think where I struggle is as
much as I'm on Bungie side right we do
have to admit because of d2l initial
reception honeymoon phase and it left
they definitely took a hit financially
must know that then I remember since
that point of September of last year
destiny wasn't in top-10 MPD's and that
was always a concern for me and if I'm a
next month play like are you looking at
the trophies more I'm looking at Xbox
has more games most played right and
there's a top 20 and during destiny
warning it's hey destiny one would stay
even in the worst times of destiny
let's say before taking King that
drought before taking cake right I
remember destiny would still be in the
top 10 maybe wouldn't fall out far from
offices people will still wait but now
fast-forward II - you've got the
fortnight's you know you don't that's I
don't want to cut you off but I mean in
DNA somebody put in the chat who is that
uh this over on YouTube snailed oh yeah
who is that somebody over there it's uh
slow-mo backslash he put mentioning
black ops and like can we just maybe
mention the elephant in the room and I
mentioned it earlier how much is
fortnight just affecting the gaming
industry as a whole for better or for
worse I mean my kids dude it's been over
a year now they've been playing
fortnight they don't that's all my son
wants to do like last year Call of Duty
World War two was our first Call of Duty
I bought it and so both him and I could
play we have to play stations were
playing on it had a blast but didn't
play a ton because he was playing for a
night more this year all excited for
black ops tab we're gonna get black ops
sure man we'll get black ops we can
we'll play in it and play together Toby
we've played it like two or three times
yeah because other than that all he
wants to do is play fortnight it you
said that English again we were in back
then guess he was kind of the new kid on
the block in that genre there wasn't
feeders level of competition what is
changing the game we have you can get
your Panthers on right now huh it comes
at all dude I already know it comes out
at 7:00 tonight and my son at 7 o'clock
is gonna be long around Panthers it's
gonna be nuts happening tonight
culturally you shift it wouldn't you've
got Sony as a conglomerate who's been
starch on we are not doing cross play to
make them bend the knee you say all
right you know mm-hm you know so I think
it's that's what's going on here and
shout out to what your slow mo said you
know as far as like X activations
expectations maybe their expectations
are out of whack I mean we have Red Dead
Redemption it just dropped as well these
are high quality games all in this same
space of third fourth quarter competing
with Destin we're not even talking about
anthem not even dude I was just because
that we haven't even brought up that you
know the other elephants in the room
that's coming out and less direct
competitors coming that's one thing I do
want to say though I think a lot of
people are banking a lot on anthem I'm
gonna tell people right now just hold
your expectations couple reasons one I I
do know some of the people who have
played anthem multiple times over the
last few months as y-a game changers or
some other events in that and the game
currently where it is is in a kind of a
weird spot I think part of it is EA
doesn't even really know what they want
that game to be still but they're
basically being forced to kind of get
that thing out the gate cuz they I think
they just announced it way too early and
whatever but I think that game to me and
when I first saw it I know a bond sis
you and I play a little bit of Monster
Hunter together and as me is more what
that game looks like it looks like hey
here's this really awesome Bioware RPG
that has co-op in it to me I'm I don't
think anthem is gonna be a competitor to
destiny really at all other than it's
gonna pull people over people are gonna
go over they're gonna get pissed and say
this isn't like destiny they're gonna
leave it where in the end it's really
not meant to be like destiny it really
is meant to be more of a Bioware RPG it
has a co-op side on it sure you know
they I think they've been kind of just
messaging it wrong out there but anthem
isn't the concern I know we've heard
before the division was the destiny
oh dude the division - everything that
they've learned everything if you even
look back at what Ubisoft is done with
Rainbow six teach over the last few
years what they've done with hell even
for honor even though I don't play for
honor but even that community how they
being able to turn that around even the
original division the way they turn that
around they're going into destiny to
earn to the division - with endgame in
mind
hobbie in mind they're doing things with
that game that people want and that is
gonna be the one that is gonna I think
really compete with destiny now I think
it's all gonna come down to the setting
do people want to be in a real-world
setting or do you want to be in a sci-fi
space opera oh and also do you want to
play first person and do you want I want
to play third person because really in
the end that to me was kind of my issue
with the division was that you go from
destiny where you're bouncing off walls
and bouncing all over the place shooting
laser beams and stuff and then you go to
the division you felt very grounded and
I've said it before it almost gave me a
headache
playing the division as cool as the
gameplay loop in the loot and all that
that was in there just being so good the
controls coming from destiny it was kind
of a hurdle for me to get into so I
think that may be an issue for some
people but I think in terms of the the
gameplay loop the division - is gonna
bring him in and I really think it's
gonna pull a lot of people away and
that's the thing that I think activision
needs to be worried about and that's
what they need to figure out is what
we're talking about the black armory
being the DLC yeah that needs to keep
people in but it's whatever those DLCs
you know the final what is it the
Joker's wild or Joker's run whatever is
the number those are the ones that need
to be hitting the mark because once the
division two is out there that's going
to be the issue that they're gonna have
like unfortunately timing wise right you
think of Joker's wild you've got that's
literally probably about the time those
games are gonna be out and that sounds
like the smallest one cuz it's like an
update for gambit it's not dammit
Bradley it's not these other things it's
like an update for gambit and other
things and maybe some activity that
feels like the smallest one at the
biggest moment hmm sounds like it could
be like unfortunately time or the other
side is like do you take Activision and
you look at Ubisoft and they're like
okay who this off may take that early
part of year spring something like that
and then they do keep doing their big
launches in September somewhat spaced
from like the October November insanity
but they know
their annual past their kind of
continual content is gonna keep
something around but they can't compete
unless they release a full game at the
same time and then they go you know six
months apart maybe some people die off
of the hype comes back but as you're
saying if division does it right and
they keep their their annual passes free
right I think it is yeah I think all the
time and like it's stewed I'm telling
you that King no dude listen full
disclosure
you know I saw behind the scene the
media at eight hours media at e3 and got
a chance to play it and I am NOT a
division guy by I gave the first one a
shot I thought it was solid but I knew
the Achilles heel I told my friends I
don't like this the end game aspect they
need a true end game the dogs ruin it
and like you said well every iteration
massive entertainment coming out with
Malta kept improving the game they kept
listing the computers same thing like
Rainbow six siege right then more moles
came out and I'm they're getting it
they're learning you know I'm saying man
I think they are coming with a Vic I am
in complete agreement anthem I'm a
Bioware God if I were God that does not
feel like a true Bioware game the story
and the choices and things that I'm used
to I'm not saying it's not gonna be good
but I am very concerned and the way
they're splitting up single-player and
multiplayer I'm concerned it's a game
I'm gonna pick up but once I beat it
will they have a true in game they've
already said pvp's not available at
launch so there's always things there
with me that I got a lot of question
marks but I am so with you division is
the true threat and I think people are
sleeping yeah yeah no I was like you
guys are pretty much saying everything
I'm thinking so it was like seriously
cuz that was me when I played division
the first one it's like I played it
hardcore you leveled up you hit 30 and
then unless you just have like a crew to
go run in the dark zoom the level it was
great in that in game as you guys have
all said it's like it's been the garbage
part of it because you can hit that wall
and unless you just love the dark zone
and don't want to get trolled all day
long that was the part that hurt but
that levelling up in that game was
amazing then he had a foundation for
something that was so so good
we haven't played the division in a
while like all the changes they've made
they've essentially made it Diablo go
through these quote-unquote dungeons or
effort what they call the underground
the underground and it basically becomes
just a palette set swap that's just kind
of procedurally generated you go through
it fight a boss at the end you get some
drops and it's it's just a ton of fun
and if they take that layer on the raids
layer on that amazing leveling up
experience like you said where you're
kind of doing the story plus then all
just free content dropping months you
know year hell even maybe years after
the game comes out they're gonna get
that community is gonna grow I feel and
you know who knows where where the
forsaken or destiny to community's gonna
be at that point I mean III think we're
still gonna be a good point I think a
lot of people are still definitely gonna
be playing destiny but I think that
whatever that annual past content is
gonna be huge at that point what mark um
they asked and I look gay man he said if
we're in charge of how Bungie drops
content in a little istic way like how
would you handle the dropping of the
content would you keep what's going on
now with like the standard season passed
away I mean with this new annual pass
that they've kind of introduced would
you change anything how would you go
about it honestly man I mean this is all
we know right now with this content I
think this the problem with destiny is
it's so caught in between wanting to be
an MMO but wanting to be kind of just
that classic console game still and I
think you know that's kind of why I
brought up the reason of a monthly pass
I honestly would be willing to pay a
monthly pass if that means or content
coming out at a consistent rate and I'm
just paying them a lump sum to continue
to play this game that I love that that
honestly I've never spent more hours in
a game world ever than I have you know
then destiny I mean this is the game
that I've played probably the most in my
life I used to always say it was the
original Mario Brothers on the NES but
it's not friggin destiny man like you
there's no other game I've gotten more
value for my money so I would if they
can promise continued content that's
might be the way that I would say maybe
try and do it just take the leap and say
you know what with destiny 3 we're going
much more MMO you guys have been crying
for it we've been kind of treading the
line now I don't want say crime crying
for the MMO side of let go that full
route and then we've been kind of
blurring the line unsure
we feel confident now in our content
because also if you have that monthly
fee that set income coming in then you
can then plan out your development right
now they release you know they put out
forsaken like you know we're gonna put
out for Sagan it comes out and it
doesn't mean expectations now all the
money they've been spending on
development of whatever the next thing
is you look at that and say we've spent
all this money we thought we were gonna
make this money but we didn't now we're
gonna be not our income is not gonna be
as much where if you say hey we have
this just set income this many people
have spent this much money this is the
money we have to work with then you work
with the money you already have and
anything else is gravy on top of that
right and so that might be one of the
arguments for a monthly fee or maybe an
annual fee whatever you want to say
rather than the let's just throw
something out there and see how it goes
doesn't mean expectations but we're
already spending all this money on
development now we're screwed
which again in the grand scheme of
things these are giant conglomerate
companies that they're not hurting at
all when they say they're not meeting
expectations it's literally that they
had a goal set in mind they didn't meet
it they still made a [ __ ] ton of money
right so yeah I mean that's the one
thing you kind of look at it's like
they're now losing money I did it's just
it's just the CEOs may not get as big of
a bonus I mean that's what we're talking
about and so it's always kind of we're
talking about that too but I don't I
think the monthly fee man if they can
promise the content I know some people
don't like to hear that and and you know
when it comes up I know people are very
just divided with that but maybe it's
not even a monthly fee maybe it is like
we pay this annual pass just become
cheap and you pay that annual pass you
get that content and if you want to
piecemeal it out
that's a good point and I think maybe
you're right maybe that's why the
inclusion of the format the of the
Annual Pass format started maybe that's
why maybe we're starting to see the
early signs I mean we logged in this
week you know ever verse was a little
different right she had you know you
directbuy emotes yeah the first time
right it's okay if you missed out so
they're looking at ways to try to
monetize but they've got to be careful
they've got to be extremely careful
because one thing about this base if we
go back to festival of course we go back
to ridiculous practices and and or
throttling like how we found out all but
they can't afford a third one they can't
afford a third blunder
so we'll see man this is very
interesting very interesting stuff
you guys are awesome I'm just literally
like almost on a sidebar on this podcast
I used to pile
I used to just do is just a general
gaming podcast like that's what I did
regarding radio and you know I've been
doing the enthusiasts life of Chris and
Chris doesn't really play games anymore
so it's not too often that I get to sit
down and just talk with somebody about
the gaming industry anymore who is just
what we're in yeah
so if you lift the iron Lords podcast
that they are just all gamers from heart
we're like I mean NES babies from
growing up with it all it's like when we
chrono triggers like my favorite game of
all time like I mean those are all
things that we grew up in so you're
saying world and all the things you've
been through it's like I know you've got
the Stormtrooper it's like we're all
basically you know big nerds geeks all
this stuff like we live it hit every
cliche we can possibly have so no that's
what it's like I'm just sitting back and
letting you go cuz like this is all the
stuff that runs through our heads and no
it's awesome to have you on here so I
was like keep going I guess we could
make this long play all day I could talk
about I feel the passion and I know it's
coming from like these are moments I
always consider like these are moments
in Union you know you kind of get to see
where the direction of things change you
know what happens with Bungie you know
are they in a similar situation you know
when they were with Microsoft I mean
they got tired of pumping out halos
right it did you know the joke is you
know you went from one and then you went
to another you another deal with
Activision everybody was just like that
was even at the point when you mentioned
earlier with with the respawn guys that
was Wars of West and Zampella I think
where the two studio heads they left and
created respawn and it was because
Activision was not giving them the
royalties I think that they were owed
from I think was modern warmer you yeah
what it was that just became the whole
thing and then they ended up firing him
and it became a whole lawsuit and all
that and it's like that was happening
when the word came out that Bungie had
signed the deal with Activision and just
everybody was just dumbfounded by that
then you know because of things like
that you know titanfall gets birth right
you know it's so crazy to see what
happens and I mean you maybe hit me
reality-check man with the whole you
know I don't know if it's d3 but you
know at some point maybe you know just
says you know what we cannot keep up
with this crease crazy demand I mean
honestly dude right now we live in a
time where I don't want to say it's
entitled gamers but like oh absolutely
well yeah and I think that's more part
of it as it is just people now can have
a voice on the internet and some people
don't understand how to themselves
properly like out a voice disappointment
maybe over a certain game going mobile
and not coming your PC tomorrow but like
I look at my kids and and I hate to keep
bringing up my kids but I mean their
life with gamers where games are free
like my son will download a new game
almost every day and his iPad a stupid
thing just to play and goof around out
and then he goes back to his fortnight
which is free and has no problem
spending a little bit of money I think
now we're at this crossroads where you
have these big conglomerate companies
who have been just controlling
essentially the message of video games
for the longest time your activision you
know even ubisoft throw them and all the
all these companies that the $60 title
now it might not be the way to go
anymore and I think epic showed it I
mean epic is a company they made Unreal
Tournament I mean hell they had the deal
with Microsoft for Gears of War and all
that had always been making those games
and finally just said you know what
we're gonna do our own thing I I
wouldn't consider them an independent
studio but they said hey we're gonna
jump in and just try this game fortnight
which had been in development for like
seven eight years really actually real
for tonight not the Battle Royale Loki
stole from Bungie throughout battle
royale to cut to cop off pub G and you
know that story to talk about you know
them using the Unreal Engine and all
that but for you hit a mark and they ran
with it and now you have this whole
generation of gamers who we're gonna be
growing up saying I'm not gonna spend
$60 on a video game
we're not will play a free game that I
mean now what for and I spin out it's
over a year now so you have this whole
all these kids that have been playing
for tonight for over a year essentially
for free even though they've also
probably spent more money or their
parents money they don't have had they
been playing the standard games but epic
is raking in millions that may be the
way for companies to go now I mean just
he'll make destiny free-to-play and then
throw in all these other things
can buy or at the very least basically a
battle royale mode Oh give me a Podesta
battle Romo that would be amazing I
don't think any computer can run 50 is
just super that would be so much fun
I can only invent like that you have to
have dedicated service but man I want to
see that in action I don't care where
you put that give me a battle royale
with like let me see 20 hammers flying
between Tobin's and throwing hammers
across the map just hoping one of them
just hits ya and reaches straight across
and you have like three hunters going
across just to kill everybody invisible
I mean that would be they've tried their
hand they call it duty has a battery oh
man mode of what you call a battlefield
that's lockout like okay so blackout is
actually pretty fun I don't know if
you've played that yeah it's actually so
take take plug G like an attempt by you
know a smaller developer and they try to
make it pretty well then you take a
triple a polish on something like that
and that is their one of their main
three tiers of that game it's a lot of
fun and that's probably help it feels
good to [ __ ] actually the controls are
good yeah none of these Metroid games
ever that's why I hate fortnight so I
hate you know I hate pop jeepers it's
like it just doesn't feel good to shoot
the guns this is Call of Duty but with
that game mode layer on top of it it's a
blast it's a ton of fun to play yeah
that's that but to bring it all back to
kind of that whole annual past thing
it's like you see Studios like telltale
and stuff like that but and you know all
the developers there they're just losing
their jobs because you know they got
extended too far then you have people
like Rockstar where they're spending you
know hundreds of hours and doing these
things but in turn you have people are
like they'll say they got mad at
telltale and they don't even think about
the developers at all who they lost
their jobs but be like hey yo I want my
other piece of my other episode of
Walking Dead you should develop it I was
like and the stuff that somebody's like
hey you should make it for frame like
these people have to spend their lives
to make this stuff and that disconnect
is you're saying your kids not throw
yours under the bus just general trust
me my brother's kids do the same thing
and it's like they're in that mentality
of like well I'm not gonna pay for games
they just literally come with things
it's like and how do you balance that as
a developer in a studio to spin
and not everything's gonna be that for
tonight magical hit that makes you money
for being free so that's like a tough as
you said like gaming said it weird
crossroads right now with fortnight
throwing a wrench into things
$60 games are technically undervalued
because they should probably be a
hundred bucks for what destiny takes to
actually make and pay for and you know
like how do you actually push forward to
say like what should a game really cost
right now I mean how many hours do you
get out of these things how many hours
did I get out of Mega Man 3 and I paid
60 bucks for it like yes I mean that's
just breaking it they saying like
titanfall 3 just they're definitely
coming you know in 2019 to so you know
that's on that's it that's good that's
another one added to the competition's
fear utilization hours for titanfall was
a good franchise I just felt that the
first one lacked content the second one
was really good we had the worst release
date ever
yeah yeah it was actually a lot of fun
the story on that's like six hours
straight great favorite mechanic from
that sorry the little time travel back
and forth in that one mission I love
that little mechanic later
oh yeah like something would be on fire
and then you travel back and then you
could get through that space you had a
kind of interest in time because like I
said it is is the is this model
antiquated you know can they sustain it
a lot of questions man definitely a lot
of questions so I mean that was kind of
the big thing is like is Activision's
Ed's I mean you guys have your chats
been saying it to his Activision's
expectations unreal because they're
making so much money but again it's like
if you guys kill a player base off you
are gonna hurt yourself a lot more than
you know giving Bungie a little more
time not having your expectations so you
get this 10 trillion dollar bonus that's
only like 5 billion like you're still
gonna be ok the pockets are gonna be
fine it's just I don't know it's those
kind of greedy corporate nature
sometimes wonders like right now in
movies man I'm talking about cultures
Star Wars you know you had last Jedi
come out but again people divided so
that's part of the reason why people
didn't go see solo but so eat
expectations right canceled every single
you know they were gonna do about that
movie done not happening so anything
they were gonna do theatrically that was
they start walking through out the
window because it didn't meet
expectations they still made
crap ton of money off solo mm-hmm it's
just it's sad as a fan to see that and
so I think that kind of the situation
here and it worries you you know us as
destiny players it's like alright well
it didn't mean expectations what does
that mean for us so what what is now
what are we gonna miss out on that we
possibly could have gotten if it did me
like what if it didn't meet expectations
what would they have been saying like oh
this is great we're so happy it's on a
great path did he bring up at any point
in this mm-hmm about the fanbase loving
the game right now I think they actually
I have said like the I mean the hard
core is like it a lot you know some of
the casuals may have been away but it's
like they game is like favored right now
so they're trying to balance I know is
either polygon or shires article
somebody basically said they're trying
to balance like the games in a good spot
but they have to get that influx back
somehow and they can't and they don't
know what to do like it's a point where
they're like they're at a crossroads as
well like how do we appease both sides
of this how do we still make a decent
release and some money but keep these
people who love this game right now and
not run them all away
yeah he literally says what's in Patti
Johnson's we have not yet seen the full
core we engage in destiny you said which
has led to the underperformance against
expectations to date some players are in
wait-and-see mode if you're in your
deeply engaged
if not we think now's the time to bring
players back so again to me when I see I
hear that you know I'm concerned and
then when he mentions you know
specifically monetization like that
because now it's like those who we have
been able to re-engage and bring back
how do we monetize them and that's what
they're and now you start to see the
little nefarious things of XP throttling
or you know he's like that not that's
necessarily gonna come back but that's
when Activision steps in and says
alright now we got to put in these other
ways to monetize those people who are
there mm-hmm
of course they want to bring players
back in but it's like alright well we
have these players how do we monetize
them and that's where the issues gonna
be done that's what's your current eggs
and player base is probably scared about
to be like don't you just fixed right
because one thing one thing I've learned
you know well what's that what's that
all expression like the definition of
insanity is repeating the same thing
expected result if I mess up again and
you piss off this hardcore I like to me
it remember he buns we started flash
playing we laughter I was like why are
we doing this at the lowest point right
right
destiny to was a meme it was a joke it
was yeah so drag do social you guys are
still playing it who plays that game it
comes up again right and you know to see
them build it back brick by brick and if
they I get I'm hoping that because we
heard well d3 we've heard hardcore
mechanics there this may not affect the
short-term you know what we see as far
as what we know about you know the
rumors that have leaked the moment
there's already the base is already
burnt you know not all the base came
back for forsaken we know that and they
risk some real serious damage if they if
they really alter the the monetization
and then the mechanics of this game to
either casual eyes it or just be greedy
and that they can't do they can't do man
no yeah I was like one time in Destiny's
life I want a full game to come out that
doesn't feel like it got completely
chopped in half and had to be remade in
twelve months
like d1 you have the whole thing about
Marty and everything going on there and
then it feel like the story we know was
different like older and was all that
whole bunch was weird and then taking
King goes big giant band-aid okay we've
we've learned and we actually had the
time we needed do it all over again and
you hear in d2 like why did it feel half
empty or casualized but also it's like
what it was almost made in sixteen
months I heard as well so I would I love
the fact that it might be 2020 and we're
hearing about d3 now cuz maybe they
finally have the time to do one right
and I think that's one thing that's kind
of screwed them over for these initial
years is like hey it's a really good
concept but you botched some stuff
that's enough that people aren't gonna
hang around o2 comes back you might get
you know as they say 60% of their player
base back and then you might maintain
him for two years
d2 ok you stubbed your toe like real bet
you broke your toe you did it all over
again
and then you come around for seconds
this like amazing release probably the
best date it's ever been
can we not do this a third time that's
all I mean that would be the biggest
thing because like as you said we had
one giant like things grew up taking
Kings we did it again we've learned art
we've been through this twice like you
know burned me once it's on you burned
me twice it's on me like people's gonna
do it a third time I think could it be
one of the biggest things is you have a
lot of competition they'll have to see
things to watch and again we don't know
what the business model is gonna be
whether its annual I mean what if it was
like you pay a monthly fee and I get
like a strike a month or I get a new
crucible but if they did some of those
drops just more consistently that would
be those things I think that would help
that annual pass but and d3 is I'd love
to see just a real full development
cycle make it into a destiny because
that's what taking King
that's what Forsaken actually are is the
full-time they mean yeah so I think I
was like we can run this into the ground
for every mark it's been absolutely
awesome but before we go I did this to
Cognito a little while ago any guests we
have on in the future this is what I'm
gonna ask now I'll kind of give you a
little bit to think about it long time
to give you a history of mine so I know
it's a lot of pressure with no like
heads up but that's kind of a point top
three moments in your destiny career
ever now for example while you think I
can give you mine mine was for example
when I to manned crota with a buddy of
mine oh we did it flawless like that
moment of like actually doing that whole
thing together so that's just an example
so top three moments in all of destiny
whatever they were for you just those
moments where there's just doesn't
matter
yeah no pressure it didn't have to be in
any order or no no no let's see one of
them and this one you know that we
talked earlier about how we've been
doing a long time
first one honestly you talked about you
play destiny the Alpha I was in the
pre-alpha oh the first time I signed in
and this was when if you guys remember
you can go back you can find stories of
this online where people were thinking
there was a music player coming to the
PlayStation 4
and oh my god like you know all these
CEOs for Sony all these people are
playing this music player what does the
music player demo is called what is the
music player demo what is it it ran for
two weeks
and we were basically in February of
2013 playing destiny on the panel that
was one of the most surreal just awesome
moments now at that time my son was what
five years younger and I had to tell him
like don't go to school you can't tell
people that you're seeing this I'm
playing it he everyday he would come
home from school asking if anybody found
out and if I was gonna get arrested he
was one of the best like for me dad
that's awesome who was probably the
launch day of the crota raid and all
experience in general of going down into
that pit and all the thralls coming at
you and I think day one we only made it
to the bridge I don't think we're able
to beat the bridge just playing with the
clanmates that I had that day was just
phenomenal I think we played for you
know six seven hours whatever it was
I literally packed a lunch so I didn't
even doing that and then the third one I
think I've actually mentioned this
before on we did a panel I think the
first garden can you read up on since I
know if you're in the panel actually
talking about it wasn't even the
Guardian radio panel was just about
podcasting yeah and that one was it was
myself and k-dubb and my son doing I
want to say the thing was prison of
elders whatever it was that week and my
son just kept dying over and over so you
had the bubble bros in there protecting
my son in that last encounter so long
that the music gave up undone the music
which I don't even think has ever
happened to anybody else but we were we
play that encounter for so long that
they just stopped
I'll never we were laughing our asses
off so much like how are we in here so
loud the music I mean it was just fun I
mean for me when I look back at my
moments in destiny it's more not
necessarily the accomplishments that
I've had it's just the fun that I've had
and I think that what you know we talked
earlier how great the Destiny community
is I mean that really is the whole point
of this game it's brought people
together it's all fun and just enjoying
these experiences
with with others yeah I'll put a cherry
over Sunday with that and I think and
much as much as we're AG d two Vanilla's
launch one cool thing they did was the
home on march 2 things you complete it
and I saw like gamertags and names of
people like maybe haven't played with
awhile yet like what am I want to shout
out to my guy Frodo he's a part player
gaming and um you know like I remember
it was like on my list I need the crotas
I mean the Krone of the UH the aurochs
gone hard and it's like when we beat
that thing man it was like we went
through Vietnam I was like my I know
he's got my back and that's one thing I
think they gotta give him some credit
like they really captured that with that
triumph when you launch the game exactly
where I was of what was happening at
that point yeah I think you both
literally said it without saying it is
every one of the moments we all
typically look back on the encounters
are part of it but we remember the
people we were next to in arms fighting
through it and this game can do is like
yes you said that's your brother in
battling you get done you're all of a
sudden like you may have gone through
your first raid with somebody and you
look back at that name you're like dude
that that guy could be part of your clan
now or that group and the podcasts that
have been started the like hands you
shake the people from guarding like
that's all together in full circle what
this game is done you guys said it's the
experiences like yours is with your son
like mines with one of my best friends
and those things that you've all done
and it's the people you're with they are
paired with this game in its community
that somehow has made this something
that it's it's hard to touch what this
thing has done yeah it's hard to clean
of people to you know some people don't
get it it's one of those you just need
to play the game and I have a friend who
I used to podcast with years and years
ago years ago when we just kind of do
our general shows and he didn't come out
when we did Guardian radio but I've been
telling him man you got to check out
this and check out destiny and so he got
destiny to when it was
this is before forsaking when I was like
15 bucks or something like that and he
played it and he enjoyed it but he like
refused to go out to find other people
to play with yeah like you don't
understand how you play this game he's
like Nana I don't wanna plan on one
other people ruining my experience I'm
like they're not this game we want to
find people that will help you that are
willing to get you through the raids get
you through these things and he just he
gave up after a little while I just I
couldn't I couldn't convey to him really
what destiny is so he looks at destiny
just as kind of like many people
probably do with destiny too as a game
you play you finish the campaign you're
done you get everything out of it that I
think he should have and that many of us
haven't so I think that's something that
you know Bungie luckily has kind of
brought back with forsaken and and I
think the hurdle that Activision keeps
talking about is they gotta find a way
to get all those people back in get that
feeling back for everyone and and really
broaden that out to more people because
yeah I'm sorry man there is no other
gaming a better gaming experience you
accomplish that with a team for the
first time there is no better people
than that
walk that talk I love that I mean every
every one of those reigning cowards like
I actually got to do what was it let's
see the raid I can't ever remember the
name of it machine machine yeah like I
got to do that one basically blind with
some friends for those blind raids if
you've ever done one those are some of
the cause Oh like you're just digging
you're like what is going on your bash
in your heads you're talking together
could it be this there's a light bulb
that happens those little moments like
oh man and it's with that group and but
it's like all those little experiences
and that's like I did I came from world
there were 40 person raids but I was
like I came in later they kind of had
the strategies in there the sixth person
is almost that it's that level of
mechanics you need but that intimate
encounter of six sounds like a lot for
some people but it is still fairly small
in those spaces that they make and
they're just every little cog in that
wheel has to be going right especially
now it's like last wish there's almost
no room for error and you know when you
get to the end of that thing and you
finally open that final chest like we
absolutely clutched every piece of that
and you get done looks like a smile from
ear to ear you're
it's probably pumping from like the
ribbon fight or whatever's going on so
it's just ah it's funny others Oh
actually this year when battle for
Azeroth came out I dove in just gonna
get that free month to play and I went
back to whatever the previous raid was
from with that whatever the hell the
last expansion was before battle for
Azeroth and didn't I've never done a
while raid I was like no I'm gonna go in
just looking for raid jumped in and it
was fun of course but like you said
everybody knew the mechanics there were
40 people there however many and it just
it was so like non-social if that makes
sense
it was kind of like I'm just gonna sit
here and do my thing where when you when
it comes down to the destiny raids there
are six people sure there are some raids
where people can be carried but like you
said everybody needs to play their role
and do their part and when it all comes
together perfectly and you all get over
that hurdle that's it there's nothing
like that anywhere else in gaming I'm
sorry and shout out to my boy game and
Annika's in the chat I mean he's so fun
to play RAID with and now I'm one of the
guys like like he's got these great
ideas and that sounds like it's gonna
work and the next thing you know it's
like it runs I said that light bulb goes
off and I'm like wait a minute we may
have something I'm just I'm just
thinking of the cable guy and knowing
the ball the dodgeballs and just fun
moments and sliding underneath the gun
just oh it's so many moments that
destiny has like yeah it's the best
I'll preface it cuz he once gets mad
when I say it's the best cooperative
experience he says he throws as Wow
faint in the car no but I will say like
destiny raised in my opinon console is
the greatest cooperative experience I've
ever again there's nothing like a
destiny ray in my opinion hard are you
of that so well you handled that
question a lot easier but you've
probably been asked it a few times
before I guess but yeah took us a little
longer to think of it you're just like
bam bam bam I was like well that's not a
challenge I gotta come up with something
I get asked that all the time you know
that's I mean even you know yeah people
are always asked what's your favorite
moment from destiny one a few times six
years man so it's we've been around the
block destiny one man this has been
awesome like it sounds like we could
probably talk for another couple hours
but we all do have a little bit of life
but yeah this has been amazing Owen if
they
you for coming on this has been so much
fun and again one of those times where
we get to the end and we're like it was
like the day or two before I was like I
wonder what we're going to talk about
can't wait for 12:00 and then this whole
thing happens and we go off on an
hour-and-a-half tangent on sales and
speculation then talking about the
vision and anthem or like all right cool
that's what happens every time we do
these so flashpoint by title is
deceiving I'm not watching Long Point
Long Point indeed so I should put
flashing quotes actually up there
there'd be kind of a funny inside joke
but yeah I just want to thank you just
for chat for you guys have been awesome
today I haven't been talking as much
just because I've been like knee deep
listen to everything you guys are saying
it's been awesome today so for me and
again just first podcast I listen to I
also know like IGN I've listened to
other ones like as you said giant bond
there's so many that I listen to
but you guys were literally the first so
it was like from my side like I can't
thank you enough thank you for having me
here man you know I'm glad to hear that
that again like I said before I I I
appreciate the fact that so many people
now have discovered podcasting because
of Guardian radio so if anything when
when all said and done at the end of the
day you know and when we record that
final episode of Guardian radio I can
only man and look at that you know that
people have discovered podcasting and
dude anytime you guys wanna have you
back man I would back you know talk
talking destiny talking video games is
something that I just I love doing that
so back to absolute pleasure man you
have here just listening to you like I
said I consider you on that that destiny
Mount Rushmore is better paved the way
and you guys high level and I love the
panel you got everything's cool met
everyone everyone's really cool and just
to see you guys continue to do it man
it's great honor to have them of course
you're more than welcome to come back
anytime anytime all right awesome guys
man thank you all right well I guess
we'll wrap it up mark first yeah I mean
where can they find you especially if
they you know I'm if they haven't heard
of you I'd be fine Guardian radio you
know you can obviously Google Guardian
radio you'll find us all over but a
website is the guardians of destiny calm
which honestly there isn't really much
happening there I mean there's even
weeks where I don't even post the
website
or the podcast up there just because
it's like you know what people are
getting in their feeds or finding you
that you know whatever podcast service
they use but of course on iTunes Search
Guardian radio you can find our feed
there any of the podcast apps that are
out there you can find us we do our show
on Mesa Sean's YouTube channel now we
made that switch about six months ago
now youtube.com slash Mesa Sean and you
can find the show live there every
Monday night as well as the archived
version of it over there and I follow us
on Twitter at guardians of D because
we're all guarding the D which are teen
radio was taken guard to be fair
Guardian radio was taken so guardians of
D could find this air on Twitter and I
personally you can find me at mark Turk
that's mark2 RC and I think you'll just
find me just tweeting about nerdy stuff
like you guys have mentioned you know we
I do there I used to do paragon radio
don't do that anymore
we were doing the enthusiasts life which
actually we've kind of wrapped up my
buddy Chris and I were just gonna just
keep doing this Doctor Who show which is
just a crazy show that we started were
we've seen all these people to love
Doctor Who and I've always wanted like
what the hell is with it if you watch an
episode of Doctor Who that is the
wackiest show that is out there so
basically every week we're starting from
the beginning going through just
laughing our asses off just breaking
down the show it's funny and we're
really I don't even know who our
audience is we're like we're two
American guys who've never watched this
show so I'm hoping most of our audience
or British people who are real big fans
of Doctor Who listening to us two idiots
talking but it's more of a reason for me
and Chris I mean we went to kindergarten
together we've been friends all
throughout school it's really just a
reason for us to get together once a
week and have some laughs if you want to
come along that show is called the tardy
TARDIS because we're TARDIS is a little
thing about we're coming late to it or
tardy so then it just sounds funny it's
already TARDIS and other than that I
think that's probably you know the best
places to find me out there yeah kognito
what about you men Twitter and I've seen
hosts to iron Lords podcast man absolute
first well absolute pleasure before you
come into a wee bounces told me you were
coming through I was like I was fanboy
and out I was like
I gotta cook them up and it drove it
okay yeah that's what we do in the realm
of the Lord's it's every Sunday or
during football season 11 a.m. Eastern
Standard on the iron law podcast YouTube
channel Lords will be in the realm this
Sunday we got a fairly decent show I
think we have a Dreamcast guy and kids
move on we will be discussing the
breakdown of EXO 18 in Mexico City to
see if Xbox is on the right track
hey that's hurt today tomorrow it's
maybe it's I think it's take and
tomorrow's yeah mixer scream and see
what's going on so we're gonna break
that hold stuff down see if any studios
get announced all that good stuff as
well as some really cool topics you know
going on so again every Sunday is the
Lord's Day 11:00 a.m. Eastern Standard
catch that and we're also on the famous
oh you know the audio media as well
spotify all that good stuff and check us
out and obviously you know that flash
point every friday nani well my brother
my brethren he boxes always talking to a
destiny talk and it's i'm so glad it's
moments like this that it really comes
home you really appreciate it and just
talking to other passionate content
creators and we have marked the legend
the day so my bags complete i made it
now I'm good yeah seriously like bandits
I was like never quite know how it's
gonna go I haven't guessed or anything
like that but I mean your podcast
professional seriously like you could
run the whole thing without us even here
but no it's been it's been an absolute
honor of pleasure is definitely on this
side of the table so thank you very much
big fan of a long time
mine's pretty simple it's Eve on ttis
everywhere kind of a good thing about
having a weird name easy to find but
it's twitch Twitter YouTube for you guys
lately just all the support lately for
all my stuff lately has been crazy so
for me just my channel you guys just
keep it coming I can't thank you all
enough for the support it's been great
videos bro
ask you mark have you done shattered
thrown yet I haven't no haven't yet no I
was gonna say like that shattered throne
is the one is almost my favorite thing
from this because I never saw it coming
and it's so cool it's like the perfect
three man thing that you'll ever feel
like it's exactly what it was to enter
it old you know your your whole squad
what light levels
everybody be at least to finish it about
580 you can go in and do the first area
we did about 560 maybe I got to the main
odor in the middle about 580 and got
worked we're not about 585 590 yeah you
can do it at that point but it's
definitely little Kashia oh yeah that'll
wrap requests Thank You chats been
awesome both sides of it mark again
can't thank you enough and I think
that's where we're gonna wrap it up so
thank you guys for tuning in it's been
amazing
you guys know where to find all of us
and we'll see you guys next week later